you may have heard
there's been ongoing riots but not black
lives matter not antifa this time
the riots are taking place in spring
break miami
where over 1 000 arrests have been made
and apparently the cops came out with
pepper balls because
well people are shutting down roads
they're refusing to disperse
and according to one headline several
women began twerking on a police car
two officers were injured now i i have
to say like upon reading the headline
they really do make it sound like the
cops
got injured from the twerking i'm not
entirely sure that's what happened so
we'll have to go into the story
but there there are tons of viral videos
coming out now where
women in miami during spring break are
just like blocking
roads just walking on the street they
all randomly just start twerking in the
street
it is a sight to behold and this
contributes to the cops coming out with
pepper balls which is a really
weird story so we got that we're gonna
get into that and cancel culture is in
the news because apparently
well look for the longest time the woke
thought it wasn't racist to
insult asians and now they've decided
that's not true and asians are
marginalized so all these old statements
are coming back up
people are going to lose their jobs one
woman she's like a writer for robot
chicken is getting just dragged across
the coals
and that'll be interesting another big
story cnn is accused of of staging
or knowingly running staged video of a
migrant border crossing so we'll talk
about this
a bunch of other stuff we are joined
tonight by comedian chrissy mayer
hello thanks for having me do you want
to just briefly introduce yourself oh
yes uh my name is chrissy mayer i
am a comedian uh new york based i have a
podcast called the chrissy mayer podcast
which you can see
on youtube itunes spotify soundcloud uh
new episodes
tuesday through friday i interview
comedians
porn stars libertarians there's
something for everybody
and i have a big stand-up comedy tour
coming up
right now actually um check out my
website chrissymayer.com for tickets
hopefully i can uh do stand up in a city
near you
wow that was like the best introduction
anyone's done great like oh i guess i do
a thing or whatever
thanks wow we also released
[Laughter]
yeah i'm going to be laughing a lot
tonight i'm super excited about this
show let's get going
yeah maybe i forgot to pull up oh yeah
we're very well prepared this evening
there we go so before we get started
head over to timcast.com and become a
member
to get exclusive tim cast irl segments
that you can only get at timecast.com as
a member they don't appear anywhere else
so we've got really great stuff we got
lieutenant colonel alan west we had
coach lichter
we had kim iverson scott pressler really
really awesome and this is a whole
library of content i mean
we probably have what like over 100
videos maybe not at this point yeah
all of this exclusive members only stuff
we have one with ryan long
we have one where jack murphy talks
about how progressives can't be
alphas because marxism is objectively
anti-masculine and uh we have a good
argument about it so go to timmy.com
become a member
don't forget to like share subscribe hit
the notification bell and if you're
listening on itunes or spotify give us
five stars
because we love you and we need your
support all right let's get into this
first
story because this is the greatest
headline i've ever seen all right check
this out this is from
local10.com wild night in miami beach
women twerk on police car two officers
injured
so my question right away is uh did the
cops get hurt
from the twerking undoubtedly
i'm imagining cops be like stop come out
with your legs up
you know all right okay so this this
story is actually from march 12th but i
want to read it because it now it's
actually getting really crazy
they say it was a wild friday night in
south beach there were even women who
jumped on a police
car to twerk the city is swarming with
spring breakers
miami beach officer ernesto rodriguez a
spokesman for the bar for the department
said two officers were injured while
dealing with a very large crowd
near 8th street and ocean drive so
perhaps twerking was involved
while taking a subject into custody
officers were forced to utilize
pepper balls to disperse members of the
crowd who were disorderly and
surrounding officers
several subjects have been detained two
officers were injured
and have been transported to the
hospital more police officers are
enforcing the rules in the area of ocean
drive and collins
and washington avenues from 5th to 16th
street including espanola way
all package liquor sales ceased after 8
pm so apparently now what's going on is
there's like this crazy curfew
we got this story just from today from
the guardian more than 1 000
arrests as miami beach pushes spring
break curfew
into april police condemned phrase of
pepper balls to break up crowds now
apparently over a couple weeks
spring break curfew in place between
thursdays and sundays
now i don't know if you guys have seen
all these viral videos that have come
out it's crazy out there
a little bit of them it's pretty crazy i
mean are they using salt balls as well
that way maybe they can salt and pepper
balls
a lot of these are happening at
restaurants exactly perfect
yeah right people aren't paying their
bills yeah do you see the video there's
like a video where two weight two guys
wearing aprons
just chasing a dude full speed down the
street and then he tries to get away
he's like
do walking then he ducks out he does
like a ninja roll oh yeah and they start
they like they pin him to the ground and
then drag him and then he yeah he jumps
out and then he rolls
dude what's going on with this man just
don't order as many drinks you know just
like order what you can pay for
it's shocking it's chaos like there's
there's a video so there's
a threat going viral that's talking
about how these are not people from
miami
like miami did really well and i guess
what some people are saying is that
because florida's basically like no
covid
tons of like no lockdown tons of people
are like well then we have to go to
florida
because you can't do it in new york or
some of these blue states so they're all
coming to florida
red state for now swing state but red
for now where there's no restrictions
and they're just going crazy like
there's one video i saw where
apparently there's like cars in an
intersection and then a bunch of women
just walking down the street
all just stop and then it's like
synchronized twerking it's like the
craziest thing
i mean that is gonna stop traffic if
you're low on like
people to help you cross the street like
just send a lady twerking out there and
she'll help divert traffic yeah it's
like if you've got
kids coming out of school yeah yeah you
don't need to hire a crossing guard
anymore just
horsing guards twerking differences
so so for real so like why why is why is
this happening i mean it's just
because there's too many people they're
overwhelmed or people have been cooped
up
for too long they gotta just they're
sick of they haven't been twerking for
like a year now true
that's fair so given the opportunity
they just break out in a twerk yeah it
seems like it's supposed to be spring
break from school but a lot of those
people i mean is school even open
or people were even they even know
they're doing online school now
and they're just showing up and twerking
in the streets it's like i was wondering
you'd think that new york would be the
state that would be getting wrecked
because they're the one that shut down
but all those people that are flooding
to florida and wrecking florida there's
nothing to come to new york for where do
you get a flood in new york city
for like a hot dog stand like the are
the hot dog stands
open barely yeah they're like covered in
plastic it's it's a
really nice yeah it's like are you in
new york yeah yeah
comedy club some things are opening up
april 2nd so we'll see
there's some hope but it's it's the
city's dead it's like somebody sucked
the soul out of it
i don't know i saw a video from a guy
who was walking down the street in a
really
wealthy area saying that it was totally
fine oh oh well having money helps i
guess
yeah yeah i guess the poor areas that
are shut down it's interesting to see
the amount of chaos you get from like
totally apolitical
things like spring break when there's
just enough people who don't care
they go crazy the funny thing about it
is we're probably seeing
more like i guess anarchy than you see
with actual anarchists not the weirdest
thing and i mean like left anarchist
types
i don't like calling them anarchists
because the people get violent like
auntie they're not really anarchists but
let me rephrase that when antifa goes
out they fight with cops
these people are just like robbing small
businesses not paying bills
shutting down traffic it's random you
know
yeah it's totally random they're just
like you know what i can't work over
zoom
i have to go out into the street and
just spread your legs
yeah man your muscles you gotta meet
that you gotta meet that spring break
boyfriend like in the first couple of
days and then you have a week of
you know hookups yeah yeah one thousand
arrests though smart yeah check us out
the guardian says police say they have
arrested more than a thousand people
about twice as many as
last year during this spring break
season they say the curfews are
necessary to maintain order
according to local cbs affiliate city
manager raoul
aguila told the news station that he
believes visitors have traveled to miami
beach to engage in lawlessness
and anything goes party attitude aguila
claimed many visitors
are not patronizing local businesses or
spending tourism dollars during their
time in florida
then miami herald reported that police
have utilized pepper balls to disperse
crowds several times this spring break
season
describing the tactic as balls that are
fired at the ground that emit tear gas
forcing people within a certain distance
to move to avoid the eye irritant
the miami beach police chief richard
clements told the paper that officers
fired the projectiles because the crowd
had begun to surge towards officers this
is crazy
quote i think officers felt threatened
at the time he said adding that at least
five
officers have been injured during spring
break this year
video of large crowds and tear-gassing
by police in the city have circulated
online
it's like on a scale of one to three of
of groups that engage in violent and
dangerous riots it's like the most
egregious number one is like random
people partying
followed by antifa followed by like
trump supporters
just because those are the only groups
that are actually engaging this i think
that's i'm kidding by the way
because antifa literally and black lives
matter burned down an entire city
but these people are getting super drunk
and that's when stuff can go haywire
like the animal comes out yeah yeah
there's definitely a venn diagram of
like people who would throw a chair
like through a window and it's like
spring breakers like
antifa yes yeah yep yep
spring break these people are antifa
yeah they got like sticks up their butt
you know they really need this maybe
that's what's happening
maybe they're so uptight you know they
show up to this party like
thinking they're gonna party but then
just everyone's having a good time and
then all sudden some dude throws a chair
through a window you know what i mean
and they've been so covered up for a
year they've been like
their costumes or whatever they're not
costumes they're get ups it's like
they're all covered up they're pale they
need to get out
true they need their vitamin d no you
know the some of the most destructive
riots i've seen
obviously not the most have been just
like sporting events and then you hear
this from a lot of people on the left
they'll be like
hokum win you know people riot over
their sports team winning it's no longer
cruising like
dude we criticized that it's crazy i
remember when the white sox won the
world series like however many years
like a decade ago
long time ago longer than a decade ago
man this was probably like
13 years ago uh they were crazy stories
like
my friends were telling me that a guy
there's just tons of people in the
street on the south side of chicago
and they're all just like screaming and
drunk and like shaking cars and flipping
them over
and then he said like a guy was driving
down archer and then just like swerved
to dodge the crowd
crashed into a pole and then jumped out
and started cheering
and then ran into the crowd like leaving
his car there like people go
crazy people get excited for their
sports teams
yeah they get i guess i guess i have to
wonder about this because like
is that what is what really drives
things like the you know minneapolis
when it got burned down
just random people taking advantage and
fluffing up the ranks
you know what i mean probably taking
advantage like these people that aren't
paying their tabs they're eating at
restaurants and then jumping
yup that's that's big that's big time
what's that sorry i mean
i'm just imagine like this is all so
pre-planned you're like ordering you're
like okay i don't want to eat too much
because when i get into a fight like i
don't want to
you know this is freaking full i'm gonna
throw it up i wanna be full
like i don't want to puke while i'm
throwing someone's head into
into the sidewalk yeah physical physical
activity after you eat a bunch of food
it's just
it's like oh you know it doesn't feel
good you gotta have a rest period
yeah so you know yeah a lot of wigs
coming off i mean you got to be prepared
i don't know it's giving me anxiety just
thinking about it this is freaking me
out
like what to wear and i don't know how
it happens in these fights like
the women just end up like partially
nude like
thongs are out all of a sudden you'll
turn around like they'll be fighting and
then someone's top someone's like
boobs will be out you'll be like how did
that oh god happening
because they're just it's just crazy to
hear this you know
i wasn't expecting it but i'm not
surprised i guess people have been
locked up for so long they've gone
insane
like a lot of people are just going
crazy so like you you were mentioning
this but also i think
when you factor in there's very few
places to actually go you get critical
mess
now they're just in miami and they're
just twerking and
stealing drinks and when you have pent
up energy it's like guys
the guys that wanna fight are gonna go
out looking for a fight and the girls
that like
wanna fight you know what i mean you're
going out kind of with that energy or
you're like just gonna hook up it's the
fight videos are crazy yeah there's a
lot of videos like there's a big viral
thread
there's a lot of racist threads too
because there's a lot of
just like people like sharing these
specific videos but
there's a lot of different people doing
a lot of crazy stuff it's almost like a
sporting event but just
no reason at all right and there's
anti-cop sentiment
i i imagine yeah because i've read that
like the cops like this has been
building up over time it's not
it's obviously not a covet thing it's
like it's building up over time and like
going back to 2019 um a lot of these
cops i've read are afraid to basically
do their jobs because they don't want to
be accused of
racist policing yeah so when you get
like people blocking intersections and
twerking and the cops get hurt i
i bet there's a lot of people down there
they're probably not super political
but the black lives matter narrative
really does permeate everything
so i we just went we're at the mall
they're hanging out and we went to
zumi's
and there was a poster on the wall that
was just like it was the weirdest thing
for me
to see in the zoomies it was like a
poster that said i stand with
black lives matter brianna taylor free
healthcare
increasing the minimum wage and i'm like
i'm in a mall
skate shop what is this like why is
there a poster for black lives matter
beyond a tailor
but also like that i could get i suppose
but like the
the the democrat talking points were on
that too
and i'm just like it's kind of weird to
see i don't care whatever you can put
whatever poster you want i don't care
i'm gonna buy shoes or something
but it's just like when regular people
who normally don't engage in this stuff
are getting hit with this i i'm willing
to bet there's
anti-cop sentiment for sure in the
spring break riots where they're just
like half the police you know what i
mean
why don't all of us go to miami right
now and start twerking
in the street i think that would help
narrative how'd that mean
i got a better idea why don't we get the
cops to twerk with the people in the
street that's what we needed
solidarity yeah in solidarity you know
like if it's enough twerking maybe it'll
be like a care bear stare
we're like an energy like everyone comes
together and that's how unity happens
maybe maybe like dr you know when all
the cops took a knee during the black
lives matter stuff
maybe the cops need to take a twerk yes
and they should all go out there to
apologize for using pepper balls on
people
take a tour guys twerk during the
national anthem at a basketball game or
whatever and
definitely dissolve tension it would
crack people up i've
freak people out do you think they're
gonna cancel spring break next year
how can you cancel spring break i don't
know you can't cancel it it's not it's
not really a thing it's like people just
showed up
people just went to florida and then
there was too many people
i'll tell you what freaks me out is like
is this what people do when there's too
many people
somebody somebody messaged us like last
week about the rat utopia experiment oh
yeah
have you ever heard of this no they
created the space where they put a bunch
of rats
in this rat house you mean new york city
yeah so basically they made a model of
new york and i'm kidding they they took
like a rat city
and they gave him an unlimited supply of
food and water
and whatever and they just like went
nuts apparently started eating each
other
some just literally just dropped dead so
like they reproduced and reproduced
and then eventually they reached like
this massive population but there was
still just free food
nothing to worry about and then they the
rats apparently started breaking down
going crazy
eating each other and just dying and so
i'm wondering like
you get too many people and this is what
we see like i was in new york when i
can't remember which new york team won
the super bowl or something was back in
like 2012 i think i don't know i don't
know sports you guys give me the right
year
people were just like throwing garbage
cans and trash everywhere just flipping
things over
and it was just tens of thousands of
people walking through the streets just
trashing everything for for no reason
yeah if somebody else starts doing it
it's easier to chime in i guess and i
think part of the reason
is i think people are afraid to go like
you think about the normal spring break
destinations cancun maybe ibiza
i'm saying it wrong it's supposed to be
ibiza but uh maybe people are afraid to
travel internationally now
because of health stuff so maybe that
means everyone's just going to stay
domestic and then go to florida
yes which brings him to we'll jump over
the next story on this one because it's
how crazy things have gotten with covid
so
when you when you see what's happening
in miami and this insanity
i'm not surprised that people are doing
crazy stuff because people kind of lost
their minds over the past year
i'm sure most people who are listening
to this can probably relate in some way
to how
awful the lockdowns were i immediately
got out of the city i went to the middle
of nowhere well not immediately i mean i
was in the suburbs already so things
weren't that bad
and then we went out to the middle of
nowhere where things are fantastic
you ask somebody who lives in the middle
of nowhere how's the lockdown been
they'll
haven't noticed check this out we got
this from express.co.uk
holidays overseas to be made illegal
five thousand pound fine for people
trying to leave britain
if you if you if you're in britain and
you try to leave
they will fine you 5 000 pounds which is
basically like seven grand
damn yeah yeah so i'm i'm glad i don't
live there
but i can imagine people are gonna start
going crazy like you know you know
what's really crazy about the story is
the uk is basically now the plot of v
for vendetta like
almost the v vendetta plot is i saw it
so long yes sam
so it's basically and again i'm
explaining the plot for v for vendetta i
am not
asserting any conspiracy theories about
covent v for vendetta
is about these like corrupt politicians
and
and cr you know crony corporate types
who
manufacture a virus to use as a pretext
to gain authoritarian control of the
country so i'm not saying that's
literally what happened in the uk i'm
saying it's it's making people say that
because you get the pandemic which
affected everybody
and then you get you the uk
like they arrest people for jokes now if
you try to leave
five thousand pounds what if you're just
sick of the weather you know what if
you're like
can't leave i've had it i'm gonna fix my
teeth let me get it we're all in this
together chrissy
you can't leave dang this is the crazy
thing too because i've been hitting up
people like
you know i hit up count dankula and i
hit up carl benjamin i'm like yo when
can we get you out here
things are starting to improve over here
across the pond and they're like if we
try and leave we'll be like arrested and
fined
they could just scary get five and then
what happens if you don't pay the fine
i imagine they'll like maybe like danke
will just take it from your bank account
or they'll arrest you or something
god i don't know get a disguise well no
you're supposed to leave
you you go to the airport and they used
to arrest you take this out from the
telegraph
people caught without a reasonable
excuse for travel will be in breach of
regulations
from march 29th under new roadmap rules
you got a week oh man you got a week to
leave i was going to say get out while
you still can but i don't want to
i don't want to push anyone look at this
oh it's for spring break
yeah they call it easter break number 10
indicated the 5 000
fine was designed to deter anyone
thinking of going abroad for an easter
break
in defiance of the ban on foreign travel
it will apply to both britons and
european citizens living in the uk
amid fears that anyone going abroad for
a holiday or family reunion
could import new covet variants on their
return the only exemptions for to the
travel ban are for work
study moving house or attending a major
family event which is a birth wedding or
funeral i mean that's kind of a lot of
exceptions to be honest
does it say anything about twerking
actually that is allowed yes if they
catch you in the airport twerking they
will not find you
right they must be going to miami let it
go go to miami all right that's fine
they are part of the government's new
regulations enacting boris johnson's
road map out of lockdown and laid in
parliament on monday
they state that no one may leave england
to travel to a destination
outside the united kingdom or travel to
or be present at
an embarkation point for the purpose of
traveling
from there to a destination outside the
united kingdom without a reasonable
excuse so like i guess you could
literally be in the airport
and they could stop you back while
you're traveling and you're like
for fun you're under arrest really is
the meme about needing a license for
everything
you know in the uk the joke is that in
the uk you need a license for
everything you do man i want to
i don't want to dump on people that are
british citizens i feel bad for those
people well there's called subjects
which is crazy british subjects like are
they citizens are they subjects or is
that are they both what the heck they're
a subject yeah
to someone what's so crazy it's really
amazing to watch happen to be honest
because we've we've had it pretty bad in
in the us with the draconian lockdown
stuff
but i mean wow you can't even leave it
puts it into perspective and i read
somewhere that you can't even leave your
house in france without like a
paper i don't know like a note from your
doctor i don't know
you need some kind of proof that you're
supposed to be out of your house
and apparently i think in greece you
have to text the cops
or at least they were doing this you had
to text the cops and be like yo i'm
going to leave and they'd be like all
right you're good
or they'll be like no you can't leave
wow yeah man
that's living in high density you know
what i mean so if you look at
the weird thing about all of this you
look at europe and it's like
basically the size of the us but with
600 million people instead of 330
million people
and then you hear about places like
greece if you've ever been to france
really really dense in the big cities
but it's just in the cities so why is it
affecting like
everybody why is like ever everybody in
britain's
trapped you can't leave i wonder too
it's like you can you go to northern
ireland
and then if you go to northern ireland
can you drive into ireland
and then once you're in ireland are you
are you good this has been one of the
weirdest things about the uk i'm sure
people
in the uk and uh and europe probably
understand better but you know northern
ireland is part of the uk
ireland is not so and because of the
treaty that
the foreign i don't know if it's a good
friday treaty or whatever you
there's there's not supposed to be any
border checkpoint between northern
ireland and
you know ireland so then how does that
work for
like the european union and this
lockdown could you just drive through
and then fly out yeah and then fly out
from like dublin or something or
whatever i don't know what other island
irish cities are there probably helps to
just
can you know do a lot of accents you
know you get stuff you're like
you tried the template
[Music]
[Music]
well it doesn't say australian citizens
yeah so at what point do people kind of
like just lose their mind
maybe they go twerk yeah this is the
other side of that coin right
we talk about the the shutting down of
miami due to the twerking pandemic
and when you that's like the people
saying enough and just twerking in the
streets
yeah but then in the uk it's the
opposite it's like the hardcore
lockdown maybe to stop people from
having too much fun well i mean just
from doing anything i don't know
so crazy is the crazy thing about it is
the
the the uh kovid's survival rate yeah
99.95 for ever for most people
97.5 for people over the age of 70. yet
they just shut down the entire country
you can't leave or they'll find you
that's weird almost the world they shut
down like almost the entire world
over this thing well i mean i unders
i i i get the pandemic stuff they're
like hey there's a pandemic so we gotta
restrict travel it's like it's like the
game play inc you know and the virus
happens like iceland shuts down and then
you're like oh we get in iceland and you
can't win the game then
but this is crazy this is them a year
later
shutting down their borders and not
letting anyone leave with a 99.95
percent yeah and then wasn't it like 60
72 percent of people that have
contracted covet were overweight or
obese
78 percent seven no who died of it right
yeah people
died yeah that's that's crazy man like i
i would
feel weird constricting travel only on
obese people
that that feels wrong how about you can
go like obese people can travel but only
for going to the gym
oh yeah there you go they shut the gyms
down if you're going on a hike
and you're over a certain you can't wait
no no no no in the uk has been crazy
there was a video
where somebody was out in the middle of
nowhere early on in the pandemic and
they got stopped by a cop
and the cop was like what are you doing
outside and they're like i'm in the
middle of nowhere walking and they're
like you're under arrest and then
there's another there's a viral photo
where the cops were like
think you're out for a stroll in the
middle of nowhere we'll find you
yeah no joke and people were like what
that's
creepy dude man they're they're locking
everybody in britain down that's what
happens you don't have a constitution
yeah they do right they have one but
it's not what is the parliamentary
constitution
it's an unwritten interpretable
vaguely understood quote-unquote
constitution and the queen has
all the power at the end of the day she
just chooses not to exercise it
yeah she's quitting soon isn't she who
she giving power to
who she's seeding control to i have no
idea charles maybe
i don't know prince charming probably
really good for like single ladies who
really want to meet like a police
officer boyfriend so they just
go out by themselves like look really
good like come get me
like me for vendetta i can be for
vendetta when uh
what's her name evie hammond it's
natalie portman she the
the they're called the finger men and
they stop her the dark alley
and they're gonna you know try to abuse
her right the finger
men that's what they're called and then
she's like oh no you're a finger man i
didn't know and then v shows up and he
does that speech where every words have
the letter v
that movie's great by the way i'm just
wondering at what point
any of these people is gonna they're
gonna lose their minds and and do
something
to counter what the government's doing
because i mean there was a period where
there was a large group of british
subjects who got really angry
and then wrote this big thing to the
king like yo we're not british subjects
no more
yep and we've been doing all right over
here for some time
them over there they're not not going so
well it's crazy
and all this talk about like different
countries makes me realize how little
i've truly traveled in my life
where have you gone really just like
italy
france uh canada
briefly i went to iceland only because
it was basically on sale
like 10 years ago like you'd see the ads
like in new york city mostly on the
subway like please please come to
iceland like we know you're going
somewhere else but can you just like
stop here on the
almost like a desperate like girlfriend
like please just come visit yeah they
had just like
uh overthrown their government and
started a new one
in 2008 this is the banking thing yeah i
went in 2008.
yeah no they had that what's what's that
airline they had an icelander
and it was like are you going to spain
take wow air it stops for you know three
hours in iceland
yeah because then they want you to spend
money at their shout out to iceland i
mean they really they actually overthrew
their corrupt banking and then like
seized control their government and
created a new more democratic
situation i don't know about that though
i think what people need to realize
about
these countries any one of these
countries particularly europe is
monoculture creates social enforcement
for anything they want
if you've got a tribalistic dogmatic
monoculture
then one person can act as a despot
because everyone just says okay to
whatever the machine is like you see it
with cancel culture
you know you get someone who's prominent
enough to
ignite or like light you know drop plant
that seed of some new idea
and if they're prominent enough people
will just latch onto it and then it
works and that social enforcement causes
problems forever what makes me nervous
about
god save the queen man and i really you
guys in england i'm not
doing this it's not personal it just
terrifies me that there's this cult of
personality surrounding your liege lord
like
it's crazy that's true for everywhere
with kings bro i know
but people love their monarchs some of
them i mean yeah
but like when i was in do you love the
monarchy when i was in thailand
uh you know like five was oh man like
seven years ago now
when they were doing the whole
monarchist versus parliamentarian
protests
like even the people who were for like a
democratic process
with a prime minister would talk about
how amazing the king was
like he was a really good dude who
helped out people and used his power
properly
but it's time to move on that was really
interesting to me there were some people
who disparaged the monarchy for sure
but then they would always be like well
but we really do like the king because
he's kind of a cool guy
so like the king in thailand would use
resources to like help the poor and like
teach people to read and and do things
like that
so everyone was kind of just like oh
monarchy sucks but this guy's kind of
cool
but apparently nobody likes his son so i
don't know i'm not gonna pretend to be
an expert on thailand
yeah it's usually a bad king when it
falls apart king john of england was
when they forced the uh
what was that thing they made him sign
the magna carta basically seized control
from the
from the monarchy to a bunch of the
dukes and it was like the first step
towards democracy yeah magna carta was
pretty cool and then they had to duke it
out
yeah they did they literally had to sure
did etymology
yeah that's one way to put it dude get
out is that where it
i comes so yeah that's something like
that
put up your dukes yeah oh yeah huh
you're right was that what it is
it must be no it's gotta be get out of
here maybe
yeah all the dukes would go to war man
what do you guys do what do you guys
want to do do you want to talk about
stupid cancel culture let's talk about
cancer probably
we'll wreck on cnn in a little bit yes
but i want to talk about this thing with
uh with harry's razors oh yeah
for those who don't know and i didn't
know this harry why harry harry
harry's razors sponsored the daily wire
the examiner reports harry's razors
cancels advertising relationship with a
daily wire show ostensibly over
one twitter user's complaint let me
break down for you the stupidity of
cancel culture
michael j knowles he is a podcaster
political commentary guys with a daily
wire
a twitter account with two followers
two followers just two apparently it's
like his mom and his brother
tweeted at harry's saying you you
sponsor a bigot
michael j knowles and he's homophobic
and transphobic so harry's respond
saying we're so sorry we're gonna cancel
our sponsor for the show they tweeted
thanks for bringing this up
we condemn the views in this video which
are inexcusable and at odds with our
longtime support
of the lgbtq plus community we've ended
our relationship with this show
and are looking into our sponsorships to
prevent any values misalignment going
forward
jeremy boring says harry's makes great
razors
that's why we've been proud to advertise
them for years we know harry's doesn't
share our values
who cares economic decisions should be
political decisions
but now harry's has decided to declare
that conservatives don't deserve great
razors
why are you still calling them great
razors i wouldn't like at this point
well those razors were garbage anyway
well okay all right props to the daily
wire for not being sour grapes
but this is the crazy reality of cancel
culture an account with two followers
tweets to a brand and the brand just
goes all right
i have to wonder i'm gonna make a bold
uh a bold um
i'm not gonna call it an accusation
because uh i don't wanna get sued i'm
going to speculate
wildly could it be that when it comes to
these sponsor spots
these companies know they can't legally
exit a contract
they want to exit yeah except for
morality clauses
right so let's say you know i sponsor
ian and the contract is like a two-year
deal
where x amount of times per month ian
will shout out you know
tim's fancy water and then there comes a
point where i'm like yo we're not
selling as much
as we thought we were gonna sell and
this ad deal seems to be a bad deal for
us but we locked in a two-year contract
with them for sponsorship
we're only i'm only selling one bottle
of water every time
you know ian does a shout out but it's
costing me as much as 10 bottles of
water is worth for the shout out
i'm losing money can't break the
contract right
ah but what if someone tweets ian is a
bigot
now i've got a morality clause in the
contract saying oh well you know
wow could basically be a bot account
yeah it actually could be
yeah it could be a clever way what if
canceled culture
i i obviously think there's a lot of
canceled culture that's you know
legitimate
psychopaths tweeting stupid things and
getting people fired but i have to
wonder if there's a decent amount of
fake cancel culture designed to help
people escape
contracts they don't want to be in
anymore and not fulfill their
obligations to these other companies
yeah i would say it must be because you
thought of it
i mean that doesn't it's not not proof
that it happened but i mean that's
not that doesn't sound that complicated
yeah twitter is used for so many
different things like i remember like
howard stern would talk about like
they would have these sort of like and
this is so many years ago like
basically they'd have these extra
accounts that they would use to
to help like get guests on the show by
just tweeting at people and
it's kind of like it's controlled not
opposition but like
you know exciting manipulation yeah it's
creepy but they do it they're called
sock puppet accounts where one person
will have a bunch of accounts they
control this is different from like a
bot
for instance it'll be a real person
behind every account
they'll use different pictures and
different names and so when i saw
an account with two followers tweeting
this at harry's i was like how did they
notice that
like harry's has what tens of thousands
of followers and this is the one
thing they tweeted about and tweeted at
i think
i think the daily wire should do an
investigation figure out you know maybe
file a claim or something it's hard to
do though
because twitter separate company never
going to give up user data
and it it might just be wild speculation
but doesn't that sound just
really weird these circumstances yeah
you're supposed to ignore the haters
you're supposed to like especially ones
with
so few followers yeah seriously well i i
will i will tell you this
i am shocked and appalled and i tweeted
about this and i i love people are like
i can't tell if tim's joking or not
uh harry's sponsor is a bull writer
and like they made a video where they're
like we're proud to sponsor
like the only african-american bull
writer in this you know field or
whatever
and i'm like so let me get this straight
they're mad
at michael j knowles for their perceived
ideological difference for what they
support
but they are taking a very very hard
stance on animal cruelty issues
i'm not saying actually i'll tell you
straight up i am no fan of rodeos i am
no fan
of bull riding or bull fighting
especially
bull riding isn't nearly as bad bull
fighting is nuts and if i i think that
stuff should be banned absolutely
that's legit torturing animals they
blind them they starve them
and that way you can actually compete
with a bowl because you know these dudes
don't have what it takes apparently
and then they're stabbing the bull
that's this brutal bull riding is very
very different
that's like i don't like the idea of
using a bull for entertainment in this
way
but i do find it fascinating where they
draw the line and what ideology they're
willing to support or oppose
because animal rights and stuff is
particularly left you know you've got
like penises or other organizations
that's why i question about whether or
not harry's actually cares about the
daily wire and whether michael j knowles
is homophobic or transphobic
and whether or not they're just trying
to get out of a contract and they don't
really believe it
but either way i'll tell you this
they're a trash company and i would
never use their product harry's
yeah what is it exactly razors i guess
yeah look man i don't i i there's one
thing i really hate
about companies and it's not their
ideology it's more so
like spinelessness you know what i mean
like if harry sponsored
uh uh a black lives matter guy or
whatever and that was it
and then people complained about it i'd
be like i don't care whatever like i was
mentioning i went to zoomies and they
had like the brianna taylor thing and
i'm just like whatever man
this doesn't bother me whatever people
put up whatever signs they want
sometimes i see trump riding a tank with
like a velociraptor flying
jumping in the background or whatever
and i'm just like i get it you know it's
the spinelessness
it's that harry's shows that they can't
back
up what you know what they what they set
out to do
right so they'll sponsor this show and
then just sorry we're losers
so they had to have known when they
signed this deal with the daily wire
what exactly the daily wire was
there is no like disguising what they
what they're all about and ben shapiro
talks freely about it he's like you know
that we're ideologically biased
like what would possess them to be like
oh my gosh someone with two followers
tweeted at us we're gonna notice it
we're gonna take action and we're going
to sever this deal with this company
that
this is a big company daily wire has a
lot of listeners and followers so
i don't know what they were thinking
with that no this is crazy
yeah i mean the daily wire is the
biggest right-wing publication
uh i believe on the internet i think so
yeah no no joke like
i think i don't know how much money they
bring i've heard crazy people saying
like
you know not crazy but i've heard people
saying crazy numbers like 50 million a
year or something
it's probably not more than say fox news
or whatever but things are changing
and the daily wire gets something like
five times as many
uh engagements as the most prominent
left-wing publication so there was a
report from news whip in 2018 that talks
about
left you know partisan engagement on on
facebook
the daily wire gets like 137 million per
month
yeah and the root the biggest lefting
publication got like 25 million
wow yeah so here's harry's basically
being like
we out burn the bridge we don't yeah
or or maybe they weren't selling razors
maybe not
yeah yeah that might be right i think
they got razor burned yeah yeah probably
remember when colette did that thing
about toxic masculinity
yeah oh
so bad what was that that was the
gillette thing mm-hmm what was the story
so they ran a couple ads where they were
talking about how horrible men were
there was one where they were showing
examples of
things guys do pick up a kid like
barbecuing and
be kids and play with each other like
gillette man insulinity
would never kick his wife down the
stairs i don't know it was just like
it was overly woke yeah super but but no
but also
this is a long time a couple years ago
yeah look at this it's like uh gillette
metoo
razor's add on toxic masculinity gets
praise and abuse
huh it's a bunch of guys grilling with
their arms crossed dare they
like you know what and then there was
one where i guess like some kids were
fighting
yeah yeah like in general
sure fights are bad but fights happen i
guess
we tell people not to fight you know
when you train people in martial arts
you prepare them for the worst but you
tell them not to get into fights i get
it
but the weird thing about it is like
some of the stuff in that ad was just
like a guy saw a beautiful woman was
like oh
and he like wanted to walk up to her and
then he gets stopped oh i remember that
this is crazy because it's really bad
because a lot of us women like to get
hit on
in the street yeah did you ever see that
that uh meme where it's like the woman
says
like cat calling is bad and then it's a
few years later she's like men don't cat
cat call me anymore and now i'm upset
about it i hate that it makes me sad or
something
yeah cat calls while you can exactly
last this is actually very deep because
it's disturbing
i went through just to to feel like i
shouldn't approach
a woman and start talking to her because
i'm afraid that she'll think i'm abusing
her or something no you have long hair
you can get away with
yeah yeah
the guy in that gillette ad who had just
like short hair
and he looked kind of tall that's that's
bad you that guy's not a lot
can't talk to women can't nope what what
is a guy supposed to do then
when and and look don't look at me right
when you have these commercials
literally being like whoa don't talk to
a woman walking around
what's you're a woman right now right so
what are men supposed to do
when they're told literally don't talk
to women you don't know it's crazy
tinder
it's yeah it's really frustrating i
think it's making a lot of guys confused
um no i'm i'm for talking to women like
everything
you know passing notes in the hall i
like it i don't know i mean i have a
boyfriend but it's like
it's okay it's okay to like express your
like for someone or a crush
or it's i just don't like the way it's
happening guys shouldn't be afraid to
put it to somebody right right but it is
true that if you're like if you're
walking down the street and a guy says
nice day he just literally harassed you
and should be arrested right
by day do you mean like my boobs
yeah exactly clearly you meant to say i
know this
have you seen that uh five was it was it
five hours or was it ten hours of
walking through new york as well yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah where like there's
one clip where the guy says hello
and they show that as though that's
toxic masculinity like you can't talk to
women that way interesting
yeah so like if you if she gets hit on a
bunch of times by gruesome dudes
then the one guy who's like hey is is
just it's
by association she feels like he's
gruesome
because she's over it look man there
there's like some really weird videos
there was one
video on reddit where a guy wearing a
hoodie and a mask
he's wearing a mask because he has
coveted follows this woman and she's
holding her camera filming behind her
and she turns he follows her the whole
time and then she goes into a skate park
and then she walks up to some skater
dude sitting on a ledge and she's like
this guy's following me help
and then she sits down they're like sit
down with us you're cool and then she
points the camera and he's standing like
10 feet in front of
all of these random people like there's
legit creepo dudes oh yeah
i totally get that yeah a lot of them
are my fans
yeah shout out so they'll follow they'll
follow you and
like stand there in front of you i love
it yeah but then there's like that video
about the women walking through new york
and some of these things were like a guy
was like nice day
howdy and that's harassment now that's
regular stuff
don't don't stop saying nice day i don't
know i think i think it's
it's still kind of trendy for certain
types of women to get
attention by like being victims instead
of you know like
accomplishing stuff but aren't you just
internalizing your misogyny
by opposing the feminist narrative once
it's like i'm that gif where like it's
like the person and all the math is
happening like yeah
trying to figure out how you're a bigot
yeah yep i got like um
anxiety like social anxiety as a kid i
had it you know
i didn't have any sisters or anything so
i was always kind of nervous to talk to
girls i can only imagine after this
movement of like don't don't say
hello to a girl on the street like if i
saw that when i was 15
oh it would have been like 10 times
harder yeah but but think about what
that does
so the guys that don't care will still
ask the women on the street
and they will get dates because the
women will be like hi
yeah and the more polite guys are kind
of taking themselves out of the running
yep
and then you get miami yeah yes that's
exactly what i
don't i don't know is the torquing the
opposite where like maybe what's
happening in the miami spring break
thing is that
because guys are no longer asking women
the women have to twerk to get this yeah
make it so obvious like look i am
literally letting out my scent yeah i am
ready to mate i'm ready
so because we're suppressing like the
sexuality it's it's
now it's exploding out in these in these
twerk fests
yeah yeah that's a crazy thing though
like
if guys don't ask women what do how do
women react to this i want it's almost
like a
it's almost like an inadvertent social
experiment where forever we've had dudes
basically court women you know pitch woo
but you ever see a video of like there's
this really funny video these little
birds
and they're like they're like little
black birds and then the one bird like
the male bird is like jumping back and
forth and doing this crazy crazy dance
like and then and the female bird's like
looking at him like hmm
is he gay no it's the
do i want to have this dancing bird's
children is this dance that good
like the dude's trying his hardest like
come on lady look at me dancing he's
cute
you've seen you've seen peacocks and
pens right yeah yeah he's like yo
look at my texture so you know humans
clearly
have that where the guy's like you know
trying to impress the woman now it's
you can't do that anymore which sucks
because there's so many women who
love being approached still and we like
and still like don't like to be the
aggressors don't like to be the ones to
make the first move they're still i mean
i know we're out there i know it's like
not just me
do exist but now so i'm wondering now if
like that social norm
being changed what happens to like
what's the female response to it's of
like sighing and then you go buy a
vibrator pretty much
yeah i do maybe i mean like
men are in this position where
they're told no quite literally look
look i get it harassment is bad
you know these videos are these dudes
following women and saying awful things
to them that's crazy disgusting yeah
but when they include in these videos a
dude saying like howdy ma'am
nice day i'm like that's you you can't
say that to anybody i say that to dudes
you know what i mean so if guys are told
you can't say it to women
i don't think the legit response from
women is going to be twerking in the
streets
like we are seeing mass twerking in
miami i think it's something else
maybe you were right about the vibrator
thing or whatever sure but like
i'm just saying i don't i don't know if
we can speculate i'm wondering how women
respond to this because
men are being told socially if you do
this you are bad you can get cancer you
can lose your job all the stuff
there's no restriction on women so do
women now start
approaching men you know i guess but
like
that's not gonna make these women want
to approach men like if it's in your
nature to want to be pursued
to want to be like the receiver right of
the attention like
i think you're gonna be like all right i
guess i have to do this but you're not
gonna like it
you're like i guess i have to be the one
to like talk to a guy
and then it's like and then you're gonna
get beaten out over the women that are
like
more competitive or like more vocal
but i wonder though i wonder how much
it's true that guys
don't like women making the first move
and women
want guys to make the first move and how
these relationships will work with this
like really
dramatic and rapid change in the social
dynamic you know
i think i'll still i think women will
start to develop like colorful feathers
probably yeah you can see it well we've
seen this a little bit where um
where women don't like men who don't
earn as much as they do and yeah
millennial women are resentful if they
if they make more than
they tend to right yeah and they get
divorces yep
yeah couples where the woman makes more
that they're more likely to end divorce
and then like all the feminist you know
blogs basically it's men's fault
of course it is i wonder if there's
something there too like guys don't
write about their feelings
no yeah they're encouraged not to or to
show them
see that's the patriarchy i'm told well
it sounds like it just sucks for men
right well actually actually think about
the ramifications of this
so if men don't express their feelings
and that's
assuming that's true then men are less
likely to write opinion pieces about
their feelings
i don't know if that's true maybe it's
true if feminists
if if women end up being the ones to
primarily write about how they feel
about things
then you will see in this static
gender-neutral format text on paper you
know
white you know letters on on the screen
a story about what is right and what is
wrong
and i wonder how many people actually
read the byline to see who wrote it and
consider
the the gender of the individual so how
often do we hear about
hey you know men should not approach
women and it's written by a woman
but guys when they read it they don't
see that part they just see cat calling
this wrong and they think
calling is wrong i mean i guess if women
are saying don't
approach women then you've got a problem
because women don't want men to approach
them
but maybe it's just the one percent of
feminist women who work in these blogs
that are speaking for every woman and
then guys don't approach women anymore
because like the type of woman who wants
to be approached probably is not the
same type that's gonna be a blogger
yep that's fair yeah why why like why
i think because if you if you like to be
right like if you like to be approached
you like to be like whatever the prize
you're not gonna be like this is how i
feel you know what i mean i don't know
i'm maybe i'm stereotyping
no i see you're saying though like the
people who throw themselves out there
versus the people who want
to have you know attention thrown at
them
interesting i think we may have come up
with an interesting hypothesis and
social dynamics of the modern era
yeah the women who are writing the
feminist blogs are not the kind of women
that want to receive attention
they're the kind of women who want to
assert yeah just like look at who's
noisiest on twitter
yeah who does the most canceling it's
like the mouthiest
people and like we forget like twitter
is not is not everybody it's just the
most vocal group
it's like two percent of people actively
tweet
wow and so like 1.1 of them
are left and then of that it's like
probably like you know the 90 percent of
that one percent
is far far left and then there's like
moderate liberal and establishment
liberal types but that's like
one percent of the country is tweeting
this left crazy stuff that's dominating
our culture and changing the way we
communicate with each other
i think he's got to go in the middle of
nowhere that's like the solution yeah
you can you know you can just do
whatever i wonder if you consider me
active an active tweeter
i'll do like one a week sometimes that's
not that's inactive but inactive
tweeters
just don't tweet so like true in these
they follow
in this algorithm of two percent of
twitter users actually tweet was that
what it was
22 of americans have a twitter account
but only two percent i think actively
tweet i wonder if i'd be in that
considered in that two percent even
though sometimes i won't tweet more than
you you might twice a week or once
you might be if they read this tests now
i don't think so for the purpose of this
statement because when they did it it
was monthly active users
so you might have been considered then
now they switched to daily so i don't
think you would be considered an active
user base today
but you probably would qualify for the
sake of this to clarify so the
and i barely tweet so you think that if
it's a very small percentage of people
are considered active tweeters
the ones that are really tweeting a lot
are probably like a very small
percentage
because there's probably a lot of people
there are some people who tweet like 400
times a day
blue checky feminists bloggers just like
it's like at certain points like you
have an off switch because like i get it
i hear your feelings man but
it's like there's there's there's you
know it's possible to
to uh have a diary i don't know yeah i
was gonna say to
just to to give out too much too much
information yeah
yeah absolutely so what's what's the
future that's going to be what's
what's your prediction on guys not
talking to women
the whole dynamic is changing that's
already been a trend is like guys being
afraid to approach women but at the end
of the day it's like you can't fight the
moonlight right that's what spring break
is all about like at the end of the day
you're still gonna have like a certain
percentage of guys that are like oh
she looks good i'm gonna go talk to her
i don't think the people are going to
spring break are in this world though
right they're probably not tweeting yeah
they don't know anything about this
they're just showing up and going like
party you know and then they're just
like
yes it's like the weird what's this
weird group of people that we exist in
this like very active
internet culture debate stuff
it's called nerds there are so many
nerds that make
youtube videos like i don't know it's
like white liberal you know what i mean
yeah here's what i feel like it's kind
of like you know you have new york
like you live in new york right you do
so you don't fall in line you don't you
don't fall into the same category as
these like ultra woke progressives
but you are in new york you're around
them
yeah so it's like the real issue i think
is
conservative sitting back mocking the
left
while there is a faction of people that
were supposed to be on the left not
politically homeless
going at it with the woke feminists but
the book feminist types and like
critical race theorists have all the
cultural power
it's like a great weird dynamic there's
so many people who don't say anything
because they don't want to get fired
they don't want to like lose jobs lose
friends like we've had a year of
basically like
left leftist culture glamorizing you
know stop break up with your trump
voting boyfriend
stop talking to your dad or your uncle
who are conservative
like oh like anybody who watches fox is
a horrible person like just
it's been okay to just cut off everybody
in your family
friends um so i think right the
politically homeless
conservatives that don't want to get
fired i think it just sort of
takes out huge chunks of people from the
conversation dude these people thought
that they could just join in the mob
right that when the mob started going
around with torches screaming about
bigoted
racist whatever some people were like i
know if i hide in the mob
i'll be safe it's not true anymore so
there's that lady alexie mccammond
who do you hear you hear about her she's
uh a female poc
and she was going to be the
editor-in-chief of teen vogue oh yes i
heard about this but 10 years ago
she tweeted some disparaging things
about asians when she was 17
well so you're saying she was an adult i
mean
seventeen's not an adult she was a
monster old enough i suppose
so uh basically these people thought
right right i'm kidding by the way she
was 17
it's sweets were dumb but she lost her
job and then the company lost a
seven-figure deal
so a lot of people who are thinking i
will go along with what the mob says and
what the mob was saying at the time was
like
mocking asians was okay now they're
saying it's not okay
and so all these people are now starting
to get canceled themselves
so this is the problem with joining the
uh the woke mob
when the rules change because there are
no real rules
they will cancel you because you said
racist things
yeah jokes whatever like you said talked
about white supremacy and once that
becomes taboo and they realize how
racist it was
they're going to cancel all the people
that were screaming white supremacy
well i'm talking specifically about uh
the the asian stuff right so we were
joking on this show that i'm double
white because i'm part asian
and so i have like you know extra
privilege you know more more than
whatever but now you can say it more
than me more than you ian
okay white male 1 but now now we have
this big thing about stop asian hate
and now all of a sudden it's like
now it's actually against the woke rules
so let me show you this this thing
that's going on with this writer
and then uh we'll just talk about what's
going on with more cancel culture stuff
i guess because why not
ellery smith this is the the big thing
happening right now as as
wokeness come home comes home to roost
you've got this this writer she says uh
was a witch from hell with references
writer at robot chicken producer and
host
but she tweeted in 2013 who knows how
old she was
she said that ho she said she tweeted
homemade pod thai
and then she said she did not put her
cat into it though
and so i got the joke i think the
problem with that joke is that no one
accuses thai
people of putting their cats in their
food that was that
that was a joke about stereotyping
chinese people and chinese restaurants
in america so it's just awful writing
if if she should be canceled it's
because she's confusing her tropes
and and her stereotypes just terrible
come on
right it would have been it would have
made more sense like oh making thai food
i'm not gonna
put a seven-year-old boy in it i don't
know
people make fun of like oh you go to
thailand to get a kid
i don't know oh i see i see well like
you're a comedian don't you have to like
research what you're talking about
before you just
help it doesn't help like it didn't work
just now so yeah
yeah you see like could you imagine a
community getting up there and just like
saying something that was just
made no sense and no one understood and
it wouldn't hit and you would learn your
lesson and you would adjust and you
don't really get that with twitter even
if you don't get a lot of likes or
retweets like there's people who just
they don't learn the lesson like oh that
wasn't funny or that wasn't clever
here's the problem with this with with
this woman specifically so i normally
don't like to call out the individuals
by name i try to focus on the ideas but
this is important because she tweeted on
uh just a few days ago a week ago
remember when someone had their snl
offer revoked after using an anti-asian
slur and so many people thought it was
an overreaction
hateful language begets violence hateful
jokes beget violence
they minimize and they dehumanize and
they allow for the normalization of
terror
huh this is the perfect example of this
woman she's a writer at robot chicken
mind you like robot chicken does
offensive comedy okay
they're fun i'm fine rubber chicken's
fine but uh it's it's seth green's show
he's the voice of chris on family guy
family guy is like the epitome of racism
you know right i should say
racist to jokes and look stereotypical
humor and stuff
it's fine i get it it's family guy
they're jokes it's funny what she's
trying to do
is duck and keep her head down in the
mob
well now they've come for now they've
pointed out her own tweet
she could have just shut up and stayed
uninvolved but she decided to join the
mob to protect herself
and it's only made her more more
vulnerable now here's the here's the
best part
she's responded twice and she keeps
making it
worse she says i posted a tasteless
racist tweet when i was 17. it was
disgusting and normalized the exact kind
of violence i meant
luckily i have been willing able to grow
in the past eight years
so i look a lot more like the girl on
the left than i do on the right
she blocked anyone from replying to this
it didn't work
people started coming after her saying
so she admits she's racist
she admits that this is who she is well
much like a person in quicksand
struggling and frantically trying to get
out and then only
sinking quicker actually i don't think
that's true about quicksand it's
probably just like from a movie you
gotta lay on your back if you're in
quicksand
is quicksand even a real thing yeah i
stepped in at once really
like up to my thigh it was crazy and you
couldn't get out it got i
tried pulling my leg out my shoe came
off yeah but i wasn't very deep
imagine how many people like putting
their junk in the quicksand
then you're like that would be awesome
then you're laying down
all right you get a stick and put it
behind you and then lay back on it if
you can
my friends i would i would i would like
to describe what we're about to show you
as
someone setting a fire in their own home
then getting called out for it panicking
and setting another fire in their own
home and
then burning their home down so bad so
this writer for robot chicken
after getting you know attacked for
being racist then saying yes yes
you know she knows she's racist and
getting attacked even more decided the
best thing to do is to triple down
on her admitted racism by saying the
things i said yeah go
the things i said in 2013 and in
instances both before and after are
incredibly racist and yes
violent they contributed to an ongoing
and long-standing culture of danger and
hatred
they are not excusable at any age and i
am deeply sorry
wow talk about i accidentally burned my
house down and now i'm going to immolate
myself
that'll help yeah don't throw me a bone
i deserve it goodbye world
she she tweeted a stupid joke
in 2013 that was just a dumb joke
then eight years later
someone calls her out so she panics
calls herself a racist
then when she gets called again she
panics and calls herself a
violent racist who is unworthy of any of
any excuse
okay dude she's a step down from her job
she needs to quit it's the only way
all of these people must quit now i'm
not racist i can't be because i'm part
asian alright that's for the two of you
i don't know
i don't think i'm racist well you're
white i don't know those are the rules i
make them up that's true oh god and if
you deny if you deny you're racist that
proves you're racist that's actually
part of the whole thing they're pushing
i like talking about race as like
scientifically and like
what do they call it race um oh that's
racist yeah
well it's racial but that's different
than racist yes and there's like
racism with a small r and then racism
with the big
r where it's like you might talk about
race
and that's racist with the the adjective
but if you're not hating on it then
you're not being like a big r racist no
no no no no matter what you say
at any point for any reason anywhere ian
you're white you're racist period done
that's how that's the rules so good at
this
do you like it some kind of ginger
immunity like am i
no i think gingers are like ultra white
hey whoa okay
oh no aren't they isn't there like a
thing where like they're replacing
gingers and movies
with poc there's like a text
there's like a meme how much more
colorful can you be exactly like
there was there was a meme about it
where there was like three disney movies
or something where like they had ginger
characters and then they replaced them
with like non-white characters and
people were like they're coming through
the gingers or whatever it makes me sad
i think there's something about ginger
that's like they say that you're like
double white or something
super white yeah super white my favorite
kind of tuna when i get sushi
there you go oh yeah it's good it's very
super white it's great
what is it that makes it ginger like
what do you know what the chemical is
i don't know it's something about not
having a soul mixes yeah that's it yeah
it's just it's great i think art are
people with like red hair
more um responsive to radiation
but or oh yeah you get sunburns like
sun is bad oh yeah you can but like what
you can see in the dark
right and you're crazy so that's how i'm
told
yeah okay people with blue eyes can see
better in the dark than people with
brown eyes really
i can see really good in the dark yeah
yeah do you have blue eyes
yeah and i was in dallas when the all
the black hats happened because i was
performing at a club
out there and i just got really used to
walking around the hotel in the dark i
was like this is great i know where i'm
going that's crazy
no so what can we do to encourage all of
these woke people to quit their jobs
just quit just get out you know they're
just going to do it to themselves
you know they can they can quit faster
you know what i mean they could yeah
they could hire a person of color to
replace them that would be i think the
noble thing to do
that's weird yeah they never do that
though they really don't yeah
they talk a big game but then when it
comes time to like actually replace them
with someone
who would represent what they claim to
be for
yeah radio silence just crickets can i
say i'm gonna i'm gonna take the uh the
alternate route and say i don't want
them to quit
because it's like do you want to heal
the organ or cut the organ out
and often cutting the organ out is a is
a drastic what if the organ is woke
though
massage the organ you know the liver
it's like angriness yeah yeah i don't
know
what liver every time you drink it goes
[Laughter]
i don't know i think drinking is okay
unless you're drinking the wrong kind of
drink like oh right if you're white and
you drink tequila that's like your liver
gets mad
like whoa that's cultural appropriation
that's good to know woke stomach and you
eat like uh
veal it's like no i don't know
we talked about with harry's do the woke
really care about animal rights
i don't think so god who knows what
about they just care about like
whatever's in the moment whatever serves
them in the moment
i don't think they care about anything i
mean like yeah this woman who is
accusing herself of being a violent
racist is probably one of the
funniest like cell phones i have ever
seen it's like dude lady just
shut up setting yourself up yeah
like you didn't do anything nobody cares
you got people tweeting at you it's like
30 people
so what and she just keeps making it
worse yeah it's always the people that
say oh words are violence it's like
you've never been in a
fight right absolutely that words are
worse no no no that's exactly why they
think it
right think about it like have you ever
been in a physical fight yes right so
you understand
what violence is yeah if you've never
been in a fight the worst pain you've
ever felt is when someone called you
like a do-do-head
so here's this this this elory woman you
know
and she's probably growing up in some
like affluent
you know new york suburb or whatever
it's a job well i don't know probably
california writing for robot chicken
and so now the worst thing she's ever
experienced
was when you know a girl at her high
school called her fugly
and then all of a sudden she was like
i'm like hyperventilating like this pain
what am i feeling
i was called the name and then she's
like wow
is that how other people feel when
they're insulted
some people yeah so that's why she's
like it's violence to say that
meanwhile if you've ever been punched in
the face you're like i don't care what
you call me just don't punch me in the
face
you know what's really bothering me is
her twisted humor is
basically what got her the job with
robot chicken no doubt like that was
it's
run by the dude from family guy who's
one of those it's one of the most racist
comedy shows
on the internet i don't i don't i don't
think i i would say stereotypical humor
yeah like racial healing their intent
isn't to be like they're not tending to
be racist because that's a harm yes
so make fun of everybody and they'll
like all the races no not anymore
they announced they wouldn't make fun of
gay people anymore oh so like they've
clearly decided
some things are off limits which is
really interesting because then
what about making fun of jewish people
is okay to the writers of family guy
you know what i mean like when they were
saying we'll make fun of everybody i'm
like i get it we make fun of everybody
dave chappelle does it joe rogan ricky
your face we
we we poke fun at everybody because you
know we want to
show we're all on equal footing we're
all worthy of criticism when family guy
says nah nah
not some groups we're like so you think
it's okay to
mock some groups of people not others
now you're getting into creepy territory
because now i'm kind of like what do you
think that makes it worse
how do you actually feel because look
you know i point i brought this up in uh
a segment i did earlier today there's
this super like
there's this voice actor's name tara
strong i think it's her name and
uh she does like harley quinn from
batman she's like timmy turner
she's also uh she's also done voices for
family guy and she did this one
really racist asian stereotype making
fun of women
female like asian women and i'm like
this is this is a woman who on twitter
screams all day and night about like
trump being bad and bigotry and all this
stuff
meanwhile she's done a ton of really
offensive racist stuff like she was also
on drawn together
super racist stuff and i'm like yo lady
like i don't care
if you voice these characters you want
to make jokes but then how are you going
to go on twitter and act like that's
wrong when you literally do it
well that was her job you know it was
okay no but here's the point
it was okay back then making fun of
these people was okay back then
well that's all changing now all right
so let's cancel family guy
let's cancel you know drawn together is
already canceled but we'll get that off
we'll get it all off the air
uh robot chicken you're gone uh what
what what else is getting purged
south park oh man southwest
the simpsons no but but much bigger
think about it right so i'm joking when
i say this
but they're probably hoping that's the
result like the woke want to get rid of
all this stuff they want to just like
destroy culture
and and have like this you know
revolution so they're probably super
excited the idea of family guy getting
canceled because
they've done a bunch of racist jokes i
get them it's stereotypical jokes like
making people the butt of your joke is
not the right it's not my favorite kind
of humor
like it's easy to to tear someone down
and get a laugh
by everyone else but but
and like it's it's more challenging to
make everyone laugh with just some
you know idiosyncrasy you notice about
reality that's my favorite kind of humor
i think so i see why they they don't
want it anymore but
but canceling this just canceling it all
right seems so
misplaced because like in a comedy club
like you could totally
roast a guy if you're a comic you can
roast anybody at the show and it would
and it would crush and it would be great
and then you leave oh what a great show
called the guy gay in the front row with
a picture everybody would laugh it's
like there's just easy things
and it's kind of just like these
feelings are misplaced now because it's
all in our pocket and people who aren't
seeking out comedy who aren't funny who
have no sense of humor it's like well
now i'm looking at it and i can give my
opinion right away and i feel like i
have the power to destroy this thing or
this person
it's almost like people who you know
don't have a great sense of humor are
being exposed to comedy and they just
like don't know what to do with it
they're weirdo robot people i don't know
if it was ryan long who told us this
but it might have been but you can tell
me what your thoughts are having done
comedy
i think it was ryan but i'm not sure so
i want to put words in his mouth but we
were being told
that when you're doing comedy and you're
ribbing on like some group of people not
like
based on race but like if you're talking
about motorcycle riders there will be
like you know some people in the corner
like oh like make fun of us make fun of
us yeah people like it
that you're you're kidding yourself
you're lying to yourself if you haven't
laughed at a racial
joke even the most woke people like
right now are in a room so we're
making fun of white people white people
do this it's like
we've all laughed at another group and
we wouldn't laugh if
it wasn't kind of true well humans i was
reading about
stereotypes and comedy and they were
saying that humans recognize patterns
but patterns aren't always correct and
one of the things that kind of makes it
funny is recognizing what seems to be a
pattern that's not necessarily correct
right so we have we have this card game
called right
or racist all right so cassandra got it
for me for my birthday
and uh it's an okay game i'm not gonna
say it's the best game in the world i
think it's fun
and uh shout out to the the you know the
people who made the game hit me up
because we showed it before
but it's it's it's it's good in that it
asks you a question
or makes a statement and they have to
determine if that statement is true or
if it is a stereotype
and what makes the game funny is when
sometimes the stereotypes are true
and so it asks you a question and it'll
be like
i won't i won't give an actual question
from the game because youtube will ban
me
but some of them are intense yeah some
of them are interesting dude that is
raised so racist it's true
but here's the point of the game it's
like it'll say something
about women and then who's going to be
brave enough to assert that it's true
like because then when it's not true
it's like ah you're racist or whatever
and or i guess stereotypical because
women you're not race against women but
that's what th what's funny about it
is it'll say like a study found that x
percent of people from india do this one
thing
and then everyone's kind of like i feel
like that's true but is that racist
i know you feel so racist when you say
true and then what happens is people are
like i don't wanna i don't wanna i don't
wanna sound racist so i'm gonna say it's
not true and then you flip it over and
it's like it is true and you're like oh
geez
like i have been in a lot of smelly cabs
oh god what am i saying
yeah but there is there is a question
about cab drivers in new york and their
in their ethnicity
national origin and then it asks you if
it's true i do think there are some
issues with question formatting because
i think
you know it could have been done better
but it's a really good idea for a game
that is really funny when people are
forced
to like you lay down a card and the card
says
it's right so everyone gets to see you
saying that stereotype is true
but that's the point i'm making is
what's funny about that game
is what what's funny about the jokes on
family guy right
so there was a a joke they made
where like uh i'm allowed to say this
joke by the way i'm part asian okay
you guys can't say these jokes you're
not allowed that's how it works right
and it's
it's it's alex borstein who is the voice
of lois
and they say something like that's worse
than an asian woman driving or something
or trying to perform a lane change i
don't know what it is but she's driving
and she's like how how many uh how much
turn signal do i need to megan
to change eight lanes zero okay i'll
turn now good luck everybody else
and then she just drives across the
highway and everyone crashes and all the
cars are exploding
okay clearly that's not a real thing but
they're making a stereotypical joke
about you know asian women being bad
drivers which i don't know if there's
any data to back that up
but it's a joke that's it i i've never
looked at these jokes like
when i watched i used to i used to be uh
uh i would say
well i'll put it this way i used to be a
fan of a lot more celebrities until i
saw them tweet
yeah right but when i saw the joke from
family guy where
they make fun of asian women they
basically make fun of asian women from
small tits
and it's tara strong who's doing it and
she's like you know very hardcore tds
i'd never cared tit arrangement syndrome
sure
well no but like but like you know when
they're on twitter and they're like i'm
so woke and we're all the best most
noble people and i'm like
dude the conservatives aren't the ones
in hollywood making these racist jokes
all day it's you guys
that's the problem is a double standard
the hypocrisy i never had a problem with
jokes about asian people i guess
and then when i say that the whole
people are like well let's go through
weight and i'm like well i never problem
with drugs about white people either
it's the hypocrisy you're like racist
jokes are wrong but white people i'm
like nah nah you don't get to do that
the only wrong joke is the joke that no
one laughs at
there you go yeah
and maybe that's it maybe they're just
not funny people yes for sure
for six years i hosted a show at the
stonewall inn
uh and it was a great show and then but
i was noticing like oh i'm not getting
like
a ton of i don't know like the fans
coming to my other shows or like i'm not
getting a lot of followers and then as i
grew older my sense of humor developed
you realized it was because you were a
woman and men are bad people
yeah and i was like what is this am i
not i realized
i wasn't a bisexual i just was fun at
parties so
um and then i eventually like got older
my sense of tumor
changed i like realized i was
libertarian and then i like got a show
on compound media and i'm like oh wow
these people love comedy they're showing
up to shows they're following me they
buy our merch it's like oh these people
just like comedy
so i was reading this article about a
woman who became a comic
and then quit because she was like men
didn't laugh at my jokes because they're
bigots
i'm like no no like legit and i'm like
funny
yeah you're just not funny dude you know
that's the weird thing
did you ever see did you ever see that
thing there was a woman who dressed up
like a man
do you ever see that she was doing stand
stand-up and she thought the reason guys
would laugh
people she thought the reason people
didn't laugh at her jokes because she
was a woman so she dressed up like a guy
and then did the set and nobody laughed
and then her boyfriend was like she left
crying and she was like i don't want to
do this anymore and he's like i'm sorry
babe and it's like
maybe you're just not funny
was that bonnie mcfarlane and rich voss
yeah
yeah i know those i know those guys was
that was like a was that real was that
legit i think it was it might have been
part of a
documentary i think women aren't funny
or women aren't women aren't
funny it wasn't a good example it's at
least like yeah
try that with a more like a manlier set
but
yeah did you who was it was it richard
dawkins said women aren't funny
glad people say it yeah i understand it
may have been dawkins and
i i i i could be wrong but there he was
saying like
women aren't funny because they don't
need to be funny it's true men have been
wasting all this time
what are you doing what he was saying is
that like from by from a biological
standpoint men are trying to attract
women
by asserting dominance by entertaining
and women don't have to do that so they
didn't need to be funny true it's like
they're
like peacocking yeah it's true i notice
with the physical
comedy it it helps if you have short
hair or like no
moment nothing like distracting from the
face when you move
because if you turn your head real fast
and this is like flopping it distracts
everybody but if it's just one flashy
movement
then you can like snap get people like
jim carrey was so good because his hair
was always like
static like his one
so maybe that's women with long hair are
it's distracting
there's a lot that you have to uh figure
out when you're like a girl doing comedy
because i had a
a point where i was like i was showing
more cleavage on stage i was wearing
tighter dresses
i would get advice from people being
like you know you should really wear
like a jacket and pants and like you
know
like legends of comedy like this one
woman gladys like
she's a lot of people look up to her for
comedy advice and she's like you need to
wear like a jacket with shoulders and
pants and
i was like are you talking about ellen
in the 90s that's how i'm dressed i just
couldn't do it because i like i just
didn't want to
i wanted to be myself on stage but i
would realize like you look at the crowd
you're like
you see people getting distracted you
see somebody like looking at your tits
like you see a woman being like oh is
is my guy like laughing right too hard
at her like
you're like okay these are distractions
that i can limit
without like uh tossing away who i am
yeah this person i like that
what do you guys think about stereotypes
going forward you think it's going to
keep them you think yeah you know you
know what i think about women in comedy
is that
i wonder if women are trying too much to
be like men
and so they model their comedy after
offer
they model their comedy off of a guy's
style
instead of finding their own style i was
thinking this because i saw uh nikki
glacier that's her name right
she's hilarious i love her when she
roasted i think she works at alec
baldwin yeah
oh man that was some of the best comedy
she's good ever seen
but the way her demeanor was was very
feminine
was very stereotypically like woman
and it was an interesting way she was
like she almost
like the way she talked was not like a
guy it was like a woman
and i'm like man i started thinking
about i'm like maybe that's one of
one factor perhaps that there will be a
lot of women who try to
give they try to deliver their humor in
the same way they saw a guy do it
not realizing that socially it doesn't
necessarily make sense the same way when
a guy would say it
absolutely like i'll see a lot of women
comics and they'll either
do that thing you're mentioning to him
like well they'll try to deliver or do
jokes like edgy jokes like
they think a guy would oh because these
these guys get successful this way and i
want to be successful so let me follow
that model and then you have other like
comics girl comics starting out and
you're like
well i have to be like amy schumer i
have to be like whitney cummings i had
to be
super left and i was that way when i
started just because
that all my friends were liberals like i
was a liberal coming out of college so i
just was like all right this is what i
have to do like lean into the feminism
stuff
talk about how much men suck and uh so i
think you feel pressure starting out to
either go that way and the ones that
break ahead of the pack
and become successful are the ones that
like are true to their
selves and they're true to their voice
because an audience can tell when you're
like
not comfortable in your own right and
the thing about amy schumer that she
makes disgusting jokes
that are like not really jokes yeah you
know yeah
and she's not even doing stand-up
anymore i mean she's just selling mayo
thank god really she was in a mayo
commercial in the super bowl yeah well
good for her she made money right yeah
yeah
she's doing she has like her her kind of
humor was basically just like
talking about her junk right right like
to be graphic for the sake of being
graphic you know yeah again like if it's
funny people will laugh
but uh right that maybe was like okay
maybe she's
but i think i think that's another case
of women trying to take men's comedy and
be like i'm going to do it this way
because this works for guys i'm going to
be dirty and gross and raunchy
and talk about stuff that no one wants
to hear about my goodness
and then it will work for me when when
nicki glacier was roasting alec baldwin
she was gross what did she say like um
we'll keep this one family friend
friendly but she said that uh
alec baldwin's reproductive fluid must
be like oatmeal at this point
it's different but like did she talk
about his bald twins reproductive
fluid you mean alcohol
just for the for the for the people who
have families out there who you know for
whatever reason have their kids
listening
hey we we do all right with the family
friendly stuff we try but it was like
it was her delivery it was her attitude
right it was the way she was explaining
it
it was like i believed she was genuine
like
like a sassy broad instead of like
trying to be like uh like one of the
guys
yeah yeah that's a good point that
reminds me of another family guy joke
where they're
he's like you know he they're like
that's almost as bad or whatever the
callback thing is
as like that one woman hanging out with
the guys trying to prove that she's a
sports fan
oh yeah and it's like guys just sitting
there with their eyes half closed like
drinking beer
and there's the woman going like i like
sports sports are awesome art sports
great football yeah you guys like
sports and it's like okay we get it like
you like sports
that's just not how people act you know
well because like women you have the
tendency like people please and like you
pick up what other people like
so you're like oh i want to like what
they like so that they like me and then
you grow up and you realize like oh just
just do you and have your tits out and
guys will like you
it'll be great yeah you'll be fine and
then you could just stand there not tell
jokes
and then guys will eventually start
giving you money you know what maybe
maybe actually there could be a place
specifically for women
yeah who have have mastered this you
know speechless form of entertainment
where they're showing their bodies right
we could put like you know
make to make it so easier from the move
around you put a pole on the stage
some sort of club so everyone can see
them equally you know so
that your view of the woman is not yeah
yeah and the guys just give the woman
the women the money directly
throwing the money on the stage yeah
just straight to them there's no middle
man
i love it it's pretty slow maybe
libertarian put it like on an item of
their clothing
yeah no i i think that is that is kind
of sad for like uh
i shouldn't say sad but that is a factor
for women in entertainment because
because i remember there's this youtube
channel where
this woman plays guitar she plays
acoustic guitar and she sings oh yeah
millions of views and so this is years
ago i was looking i
you know got recommended this video and
i'm like oh it's really great you know
rendition of like i don't know eleanor
rigby or something
and then i noticed like early videos
from her
had no views at all just like very
little a couple hundred and then also in
one day
boom hundreds of thousands five hundred
thousand then million million million
she plays acoustic guitar and one thing
changed from that video with no views
to the video with hundreds of thousands
and you know what it was implants
cleavage
cleavage yeah you went a little little
overboard on that one
not that far no she just started wearing
low-cut tops and then her boobs are on
top of the guitar when she played
right front and center and all of a
sudden it was like boom views
skyrocketed
why do you think i'm wearing this top
tim i'm trying to get your views yeah
yes yeah i don't know is that yeah how
do you what
how do you feel about that cause i know
it's probably a bunch of families
screaming did sell
everything that's true 100 people are
motivated by tits you know like people
work harder because of tits it's magical
people build things because of tits
that's right civilization even as a guy
i would notice that one of my videos
were shirtless they'd get way more views
oh this is i love this one i love this
it was like uh okay cupid when they used
to put out the data sets
they don't anymore because they'll get
they'll get canceled if they do but it
was like you have all these women
that this is this is also an interesting
uh factor in the social
aspect of how all this stuff works we're
talking about how women respond in terms
of social norms and stuff
all of these women on okcupid were
putting things in their profile like if
you're a guy
and you're not wearing a shirt in your
picture don't bother messaging me
and then okcupid put out this data and
they're like actually they say that
but they're substantially more likely to
respond to a guy not wearing a shirt
they're like the women who put in their
profiles don't bother messaging if
you're not wearing a shirt
are more likely to respond to a guy who
has a photo with no shirt on
like i'm not going to ask for it
outright but like if you can sell it
i'll be on your profile
that's that's so crazy though so why
would these women put that on their
profile if they didn't mean it
because they're not trying to they're
trying to sound more cerebral they're
trying to sound like they don't care
about looks in your body and you're like
oh i just lie
i just want a nice guy no we effing
don't
i wonder though so uh i i heard once
that women don't wear
makeup and dress up for guys they do it
for other women
so i've heard that too but like
i don't dress up uh for sleepovers like
i don't dress up
and like have my boobs out to go like
shopping with a girlfriend like i was
gonna hang out with lydia all day i
wouldn't like
be wearing a push-up bra well like what
about single women
they probably would so there's probably
trying to attract guys i guess yeah i
think when you're single you always try
and cause like i always remember my mom
would tell me when i was single she'd be
like you never know
you know like you just dress up if
you're going to the deli like who knows
you might get a half a pound of turkey
and a salami if you're good
strategy that's actually i think a
pickup artist thing though they say
don't pick up women in bars
you pick up women at the deli for sure
because then you find
a regular woman who's just doing normal
things
whereas like the bar is going to be
people looking for a good time
not necessarily looking for a legitimate
relationship true and the laundromat
that's something they say too go to the
laundromat yeah or like a church post or
something
yeah church for sure yeah if you want to
get an arranged marriage for your
daughter
dog parks yeah dog parks dog park yeah
no but
you know not to disparage church people
probably got mad but uh yeah yeah you're
not gonna find
uh you're gonna find a regular people
doing regular stuff going on
about regular things so maybe the deli
thing was good advice yeah yeah
okay comedy shows good too like if you
like to laugh
and you like girls who like to laugh
yeah how would you how would you say
like the wokeness has affected
the the comedy scene it's been really
interesting like it's always kind of
been an irritant over the last few years
but uh the the last year in the
lockdowns has really
it's been really fascinating because uh
the woke
like liberally comics they kind of
they'll perform mostly
it would be new york it would be la and
everything in between is a flyover state
that doesn't deserve
our time our energy our effort like
they're they're all just dumb americans
right so that's where you let out the
real racist humor just totally go away
right
so like vote comics just perform new
york and l.a move usually because
everything else is not worth their time
and so what what have we seen happen
like the woke cities are
are staying closed the longest and all
the while the whoa comics have not
developed
their chops performing in the rest of
the country so guess what like
the the non-woe comics have been
crushing it over the last year like me
and all my
buddies a compound media like we're we
talk about this all the time like we're
we're having a great year like we're
getting more work because we're
performing all over the country and we
haven't ruled out
you know any particular state or city um
and we're developing our fan bases and
and now it used to be way back when like
the woe comics kind of
hadn't had an edge because they would be
more likely to booked for like colbert
or fallon or they get a comedy central
special
and now it seems like you're following
has replaced
in a sense like your credits so if you
have a big enough following through like
your podcast or whatever
and you can fill a room or a venue um
that club is gonna be like yeah we want
we want you instead of you have this you
know you have a letterman
uh credit or you have a fallon credit
from years ago but
nobody's not gonna make me any money
yeah you have no twitter engagement you
have no following like people don't
really
care about you in a sense so who are
some of the people at compound
media oh that i mean aaron berg is
really great
gino bisconti is really great
pat dixon is a comedian that performs
there too don jameson
jim florentine was just on we had
communions of the compound
out of new jersey at tiff's ale house
this past friday it was so great it's
just
uh and compound me is a subscriber base
so it's kind of
nice there's no like fear of
cancellation because everybody who
subscribes like loves comedy and i love
it nobody's out to do like a gotcha
um what is compound media is it like um
like a multi-channel network kind of for
a group of comedians uh it's anthony
kumi is network so if you've heard of
like opie and anthony
um from syria so it's anthony comey's
network he started like maybe five or
six
years ago um just a place to have his
own show
and then he brought on he was co-hosting
with dave landau for a while and dave
just left
to do crowder's show um yeah but
i mean anthony is not a stand-up comic
but he is funnier than so many comics i
know
you got me really optimistic right now
yeah let's let's
are doing great i mean uh ryan long for
instance
tim dillon andrew schultz they're just
skyrocketing
you've got these these other writers you
know like this ellary woman
canceling themselves publicly declaring
that they themselves are violent racists
wow that's going to help you get work in
the future congratulations
then you have the hubs of wokism shut
down where they can't even work anyway
so it sounds like the good guys are
winning the people who enjoy
humor and understand context and are not
part of the cult
are succeeding gaining followers making
money
and the wokeness is eating itself and
burning to the ground for sure and the
audiences that
that have come out to see me in like the
last year it's like
they're appreciative they want to be
entertained they want to laugh it's like
they almost
it's like they don't care it's like it's
almost like the racial jokes
are are doing even better and like it's
freeing
it's so freeing like i yeah we were in
um
new jersey on friday and i just was like
just saying a lot of wrong stuff it's
getting huge
laughs um just telling people they look
like proud boys like things that you
don't think will
hit every we're crushing that's great
um rogan mentioned this quite a bit that
like comedians are the last
bastion of sanity in like any kind of
culture war
and even like historically even if the
world were to fall apart and then
re-formulate as like a giant monarchy
the monarch still has a jester that will
make fun of him and say the most
racist you know the most offensive stuff
directly to the king because
he needs humor human like humor is part
of why
we're saying it's it's a pressure
release valve yep
we all get anxious we're getting like
scared we're getting angry
and then someone cracks a joke and it
like releases the pressure valve and
we all kind of just chill a little bit
laughter it feels good
you know it pulls you back from that
from that despair and not just jokes but
just saying
true statements like saying the things
that everybody is thinking
because it's like look at our news it's
been lying to us for how long now
our influencers lie to us our
celebrities lie to us
so when you get somebody with a little
bit of truth you're like oh
i'm not crazy right i'm not alone it's
kind of like george carlin
you know there came a point in his
career where he literally was not making
jokes
and that was some of the best stuff he
ever did where it's just like he gets on
stage and he rants about how
messed up everything is and everyone's
laughing and i'm like
it's kind of sad that we're all laughing
at how awful everything is
but what was happening was george
carlin's saying something that we all
knew to be true but many were scared to
say
and all of a sudden now they feel relief
like i can what i'm what i know to be
true is true
i think that's why comedians make
excellent podcast hosts because
when you're performing on stage you're
performing but when you're on the
podcast you're just able to speak the
truth
and and it's like that's already your
job anyway it just doesn't have to be
you know and perform it and if you say
something overtly racist and bigoted you
can be like
i'm just a comedian it's not real i
didn't really mean those things about
those people
you know as long as it's not in text
once it goes into text like if
dave chappelle had written all that
stuff on twitter all those jokes he'd be
canceled right now
dude the things dave chappelle said in
that stand-up special on netflix were
born yeah like he
he literally squinted his eyes and did
the buck teeth thing
good and i was like i don't i don't know
what to what degree i'm allowed to be
offended or
like allowed to like defend i guess
because
you know how are the rules work i
thought it was hilarious
that was absolutely hilarious that man's
amazing yeah i'm like dude
like more power to dave chappelle he's
made fun of everybody
yeah good everybody's gonna be funny
when you remove contacts
you kind of make yourself vulnerable for
like cancellation that's what twitter is
like you remove
context in a sense you know yeah tweets
tweets are are too short but i will tell
you what i'm really loving
i have never laughed more than with my
recent you know just escapades on
twitter
anti-tweeting you're liberal journalist
now i'm a liberal journalist now
i've done it um he's arrived so when joe
biden tripped
so basically if you're not familiar um
i said i hated twitter i don't want to
use twitter it's stupid journalists are
really dumb
and then i realized not tweeting won't
solve the problem
it's not enough to not tweet it's not
enough to not tweet we must actively
anti-tweet
so no but it's this is do you mean go on
parlor no no no no no
a tweet from me would be something like
when joe biden tripped and fell
i would say something like joe biden
here's my honest opinion he tried
running up the stairs he's nearly 80
years old
he said when donald trump was walking
down that ramp
slowly he was like if it were me i'd run
up the ramp so he's trying to be like
i'm still with it i got
oh and then he falls over and nearly
hurts himself so an anti-tweet
is when i uh instead i said remember
when trump struggled to walk down a ramp
joe biden was clearly just checking his
shoe
conservabros would be wise to pay
attention so it's
anti-tweeting is not necessarily a
sarcastic snarky tweet kind of like that
was
to take it one step further
anti-tweeting would be something like
joe biden is doing a tremendous job he's
an amazing president and
i've i respect him highly it is not
visibly sarcasm it's just a positive
statement i don't believe
i'm doing it because journalists don't
do research so i tweeted impeach the
queen
impeach queen elizabeth and i got an
article written up saying journalists
calls for the impeachment of queen
elizabeth and i'm like
sure and then uh uh pj media which is
like a conservative outlet
when i when i anti-twitter thing about
joe biden you know
checking his shoe they actually quoted
and said liberal journalist
tim paul i'm like there it is they're
transitioned
that's right well i've always been
liberal you know what i mean like and
they've always called me liberal
but they took the tweet seriously it's
like dude dude i think you're like
extremely liberal it's so crazy to me
that people think you're like a
conservative conservatives
don't so crazy i mean i think you're one
of the most like liberal dudes i know
like just willing to yeah but put
yourself out there and get crazy
the culture war issues today are not
liberal versus conservative
and so that's where everything
everyone's getting confused it's
it's it's like someone mentioned this
before in the in the in the super chat
in
the super chats it's constructivist
versus essential
oh yeah it's like a core component of
the culture war do you think
there are immutable scientific facts
objective facts or do you think reality
is just manufactured by thought
and so if you're someone who believes in
the science you're you're
effectively an essentialist in many ways
they're trying to confuse this by
claiming science says things it doesn't
say
like there was a you know there was this
big thing that happened with jesse
single he's a journalist
and he's being accused of being an
anti-trans bigot by glaad
which is the lgbtq plus you know
advocacy group and they said something
like in their article that there are
more than three biological sex
i'm sorry more there are three or more
more than two biological sexes
and i'm like science literally does not
say that
science points out that there are two
and then there are
this is going to get me in trouble with
these organizations but syndromes and
different combinations of chromosomes
but
the reference to biological sex is
specifically to the
um i'm not a scientist uh uh
what's what are the things called
gametes yeah the
sex genitals well sperm and egg right
yeah
are the two core sex uh cells sex cells
yeah
for everything sex sales there's nothing
yes another one
but so anyway he gets he gets you know
that science doesn't say that they just
say it does
and so it's the weirdest thing they're
constructivists they don't believe in
objective reality so they can say things
that make no sense they can claim to be
in the fa
in favor of science so yeah i think
i mean what you said you're a
libertarian yeah i think so yeah
i i've taken a lot of tests that say i
am
but i also think classic like classical
liberal as well i feel like i go kind of
well classical liberal and libertarian
are very basically the same thing okay
so when people say they're libertarian
in the traditional american context
they're basically saying classical
liberalism
which is like center right politically
and then
i've always maintained i'm social
liberal center left politically
seriously you you need read only like
one paragraph about social liberals
and you're like uh yes i understand what
that is it's the traditional
liberal position in the united states
not the classical where it's like
hey civil rights are good things and you
know we we need
the civil rights act and there are some
social programs that actually work to
help people that's social liberal
classical liberal is more capitalistic
social liberal is more socialistic
but they're basically centrist you know
moderate positions
so yeah now i know did you ever see what
the bleep do we know
no dude you just gotta watch it no it
messed me up
it made me think that of of like what is
it called objectivism
not essentially constructive it made me
think of constructivism like oh if you
believe it it becomes reality like
there is no there is no and it's like
this quantum physics kind of
pseudoscience manifesting though right
yes which is real
right and there's something to it the
placebo effect has an effect and they
don't really know
why i'll i will say this i will say this
what the bleep do we know
is a bunch of misinterpreted there was
like a cult around that woman that was
like channeling some
aliens they think that you you can
manifest like
the observer changes physical reality so
there is the secret
which is like manifesting where you
focus on things there's a very
really simple explanation for all that
stuff and it's that if you wake up every
day this is what they say if you wake up
every day and you focus on what you want
it will manifest
it's like yeah if you wake up every day
and say i want this thing you'll be
actively pursuing and viewing that path
so it's like if you're like if every
time i see a certain highway
you know i'm gonna if you woke up every
day and said i'm gonna drive this
highway
you'd be looking for it you'd be
actively engaged in it and you'd be more
likely to be driving on that highway
when you're like
going down the road making a turn on a
certain road but wake waking up every
day and saying there are 50 genders
doesn't necessarily mean that's gonna
happen it's not necessarily the same
thing
constructivism is the idea that there is
no objective reality
not that you can manifest it though
there's like a kind of similar thing
there
however i will say to your point in the
manifesting i know a lot of extremely
successful people who are convinced
magic is real and manifest their
existence and like
make things happen for them so do you do
that but the more you talk about the
more kooky you sound
like like attracts like and i was i was
just at the casino
and i was playing craps and i think i
rolled like 30 times
and and all the people gambling were
just like screaming and cheering because
i kept rolling and i
so uh it was on uh for those that are
familiar with craps
i rolled a five first and then i rolled
like 30 times
until i hit seven and was out wow so it
was just like
you were on a roll yeah yeah the people
were screaming and cheering because the
money was just pouring in
so people will put bets on six and eight
to come up because those are the next
likely numbers after seven for those
that
aren't familiar with craps and so
basically the way it works is
the first time you roll you're looking
for seven or eleven to win if you
roll uh what is it i think uh five six
eight nine or ten then it's called on
and then the shooter has to re-roll that
number to win again
in between you only lose at that point
if seven comes up
so i'm rolling like crazy and people are
just raking in crazy cash
and they're just like screaming and
cheering and there are people i just
think you know i had a good role
maybe there's something to it but i know
a lot of very wealthy people who came
from humble means who believe in magic
they legit think
and i'm wondering if like there's a
difference between that and any kind of
faith
i guess i guess the difference is they
have faith in themselves they believe in
there's like some kind of spiritual
power within them
it's a really interesting narcissistic
thing no wonder a lot of those people i
know are in hollywood
i know i mean but like when it comes to
being a creative person any kind of
artists like we you know what it feels
like to be
in flow to be in alignment and that's
when sometimes the most like brilliant
creations come about
yeah so yeah like if i'm in in a good
space on stage
the stuff that i end up like improvising
hits harder than my material and that's
just because i'm
in the present moment and i'm focused
and i'm in flow
some people just have it it's i think
it's magnetic when you quiet your
frontal lobe and you go into flow state
like the energy's
fluxing through you maybe more
coherently it's called
ultra instinct ian it is goku unlocked
and you did too when you were rolling
the dice you knew what
what numbers were up when you closed
your hand and you shook it and you could
measure it
out of the way they bounced around
subconsciously let it go you know
you i don't i don't the right momentum i
pick up the dots someone knew and i
throw them
i don't shake in my hand deep
subconscious calculating it for you
i just pick it up and throw it it's
magnetic all right all right that's
that's it's been great let's go to these
super chats and see what the
super chatters have to say if you
haven't already smash that like button
because it is a tremendously easy thing
to do and it is tremendously powerful it
really helps us
uh make sure you go to timcast.com
because we're gonna have a fun probably
profanity-filled bonus
segment uh you know after we wrap up
here on the live show
and uh like share subscribe all that
stuff share the show if you really like
it let's read some super chats
the black blade says my wife's sister is
training to be a nurse
super scared of covet wants the vaccine
but she's currently six months pregnant
we're not sure if that's a good idea
with a baby in the womb thoughts
first ask your doctor yes they know
better than all of us
now that being said i'm not giving
medical advice i did read
that it's like women who are pregnant
should not get the vaccine but
you know what i read i read there was a
baby born after her mom got the vaccine
and she was immune to covet
so talk to your doctor i would say
that's my advice
your doctor knows better than anyone
here on this journey we don't know let
me tell you this
your doctor knows better than dr fauci
yes dr fauci can have all the opinions
in the world but your doctor knows
what's right for you
they know you so take advice from the
people who you uh trust and respect with
your healthcare
fisher kingston says hope luke is doing
all right
just found out that my sixth great
grandfather a john steele was
chaplain to george washington crazy
stuff and you know it's really crazy did
you ever look at like your family tree
yeah rufus putnam he was one of
washington's generals one of your one of
your dudes yeah he founded marietta ohio
and how many descendants does he have
like i don't know
a hundred thousand numbers i think ann
putnam might have been up there i don't
know
wasn't one of the guys who founded
facebook named putnam maybe maybe he
related one of the facebook guys like
eight times removed
no but like if you look at family trees
it's crazy because like you go back six
times you'll find one dude
and then i'll have like ten thousand
descendants and it's crazy
so it's like you're like wow my
great-great-great-great-great-grandfather
worked with george washington it's like
yeah and a hundred thousand hundred
thousand other people have the same
great grandfather so what else is new
that's funny
crazy right yeah especially the
successful ones man
they have lots of kids like zeus all
right
gunn griffin says bill clinton at one
point said
if you think the counter culture of the
1960s was the high point of america then
you're probably a liberal
if you think america's peak was during
and after world war ii you're probably a
conservative
yeah so does that mean if we think that
the 1960s was the high point we're not
conservatives or
the high point of the u.s what do you
guys think of american of america
it depends how much drugs you did yes i
don't know if there was
a high point i don't know what do you
mean by high points
yeah cultural renaissance yeah i don't
know that's tough to identify
i think the high points probably these
past couple decades before we fell into
the
until the cult of wokeness started
taking over
it really was like a great golden age
the 90s were great man
yeah yeah music the economic expansion
athletics yeah yep and then the
financial crash hit and everything
started falling i noticed like 2000
2000 1999 is when they when you go to
like
log in and like fill out your your
account on a website
the united states would always be at the
top of the countries to pick and then
somewhere in like 2006 or seven it
started going alphabetically now we're
back with the use
but then now in the last three years it
went back to the top again
i don't know why all my auto choices are
china
that's so weird so weird okay we got it
we got a spicy one andy tortoise says
hey tim first time super chat on any
channel
on friday you guys said that women's
sports don't have good rating because of
bad marketing
wnba can't dunk and usw soccer get beat
by a high school team
women's tennis does really well yeah
it's like a very prominent event and
serena williams is like a
massive superstar what are they doing
right
that these other sports aren't doing
right they're wearing skirts
yeah and they grunt when they when they
hit yeah things right
like if you're trying to market wnba to
people that like to see
slam dunks you're not gonna you're not
gonna sell tickets
i'm just saying i think you can market
you can if you have a show you have a
show it's a sport the sport
exists so i look at women's tennis
and i look at serena williams success
and wealth and
she's like probably the most famous
tennis player in the world
can you name any other tennis player can
you can you guys name a tennis player
the other the other williams no no no
what's the
federer yes he's a tennis player roger
yeah roger federer
serena williams i just know she's
awesome she's she's a massive superstar
and she's really good in and and she's
like the best
now you get these like you know woke
articles where they're like
she's the greatest tennis player period
and it's like well come on man she's
definitely
one of the best but she is playing in
the women's league and there was like
some famous story about like some dude
who was like low ranking who
challenged william sisters and one or
something played hungover yeah
but regardless that just proves the
point that when done right
i mean they're making more money than
most tennis players period
how is it that they they they get all
this this marketing and make all this
money
it works something something's being
done right i don't know if you guys
agree
yeah i would like to see marketing like
women's basketball to
hockey fans because it's more about
precision strikes
and like mild violence i mean hockey is
pretty violent
yeah interesting so someone mentioned uh
two nights two nights in a row the voice
of the guest is not in sync
kills my brain please fix it that's
really weird i don't know what happened
uh we did not change things but uh we
will we will get it fixed
uh for tomorrow yeah is that that's
happened is it happening now it was a
little bit this evening oh
weird not as bad actually um
for those that are listening uh you're
wrong actually our guests are just
really good at delayed mouth movements
when they speak and
there's no delay it's it's actually just
natural multi-dimensional
guest yeah there you go yep
patrick conover says has everyone
forgotten about desantis's anti-rioting
law
the addition to florida's stand your
ground all that lets you shoot looters
and riders
don't visit other people's homes and
ruin it people
yeah man that's scary wow
all right let's see d vance says
discovered tim last spring don't always
agree but love the conversation and
respect the debate
any chance of having tommy vexed on
think he'd be good
i don't know who that is yeah who's that
top gundy says the care bear stare is a
cult indoctrination method
federal premium ammo just sent pallets
of 556 nato ammo to saudi arabia
instead of covering their orders in the
u.s what's that
[Music]
their website says they don't ship
internationally
whoa war with iran maybe something
happening they gotta get a big ol
shipment of bullets to saudi arabia
or conflict in yemen wow that's nuts
man b anderson says christy
mayer and three hearts is your name
christy
no it's chrissy thanks for trying
good i'm linda too a lot of my fans
can't read or write
[Laughter]
megan cause uh i'm gonna find out your
name wrong
casa scack cos this cac pronouncing it
wrong probably
behavioral sync it's a real thing what
is it
that's the like the mouse utopia thing
so escoball
says down the rabbit hole mouse utopia
behavioral sync
yeah so blackrock beacon says mice
utopia by john b calhoun very unsettling
results everyone should read the papers
he wrote on it
it's scary stuff yeah man cause like at
a certain point humans
we just kind of have food everywhere
and you know so over stimulation when
you're when you're
in proximity to other humans and you
have unlimited amounts of food and sugar
i said sugar you guys uh that it you
become over stimulated and psychotic
no i think it's that there's nothing
left to fear yeah there's no more
challenges we've
we've made things too easy as a society
yeah disassociated psychosis that's part
of why these people are twerking
because it's just you can see it yeah it
makes sense corey thomas says the white
sox won the world series in 2005.
tim you lydia and yes ian make my
evening after work every day i'm
escaping cali to a z in 10 days
congratulations but a z doesn't seem to
be
you know all that great better than 2005
is that one that was
wow so that's 16 years ago wow man
time flies when you're old death's api
says another piece for the v for
vendetta plot
is that america was in civil war and the
media was state-controlled lying to
everyone that's
that's true yeah oh yeah and weaver
vendetta there's like news clubs where
they're like america's civil
war is you know now they're demanding
aid and
i say we tell the colonists the guy
was it named prothero yeah that movie's
so good yeah it was great
william martin says hey tim have you
ever thought about having the
rage-aholic on the podcast he's loud and
brash in his rants
but he's expressed he is more than
willing to be able to keep it clean for
the setting
i'm not familiar with rage holic i am
familiar with him he is very loud and
very brash and he would be a lot of fun
i have to see what i can do crazy
thoughts podcast says tim shout out my
podcast this is my fourth super chat
love the show and keep it up
that is a shout out for the crazy
thoughts podcast talk about the most
effective and cheapest advertising you
can get for a five dollar
super chat nice there you go clever
top gun he says did you see dank's video
uh
no more offensive speech in scotland
jail time and fines for saying
your mind at home yep wow
what is offensive jason solo says
britain has had a constitution for more
than 800 years guys it's called the
magna carta
please learn about the location you're
talking about before you talk about it
to thousands of people online
look i don't know anything about no
magna carter all i know is that i watch
carl benjamin videos and i remember
there was something about an unwritten
constitution
which makes it hard for them to enforce
things and everybody knows carl benjamin
is a better source than jason solo
because jason was the now not
the now retconned son of han right is
that that's what it was yeah
yeah so he doesn't exist he came back
yeah he came back from the
the half kidding by the way i don't know
sorry jason the civic nationalist says
british subject we do not revolt the
queen is not going to abdicate
we do not need a constitution there is
an unwritten rule that laws are for the
towns and cities not the countryside
the monarchy is over 1000 years old god
save the queen
oh thank you for the super chat good sir
mayor bear says traveling
internationally is a pain in the a right
now
so spend less and travel domestically
that's why florida is
big this spring break that's right man
we got a ton of super chats we get
we get too many super chats sometimes
yeah that's what does it yeah they're
all
saying tits yes every single super chat
one
they're super short
timothy ike says have you read have you
heard of the german made television show
babylon berlin on netflix and it is
crime drama centered around the berlin
police department in 1929 just before
the rise of national socialism
interesting
black rock beacon says oh wait there's
something else that that is a part two
it looks like
blackrock beacon says if you are having
trouble approaching women go build your
confidence by doing hard stuff
the harder the task you set up to to
master the more confident you will be
when you master it rinse and repeat
until women aren't scary no because then
you're gonna you're gonna mansplain to
the women
right so let's say you're a guy who gets
really good at say you know
lumberjacking
and then there's some woman who's
hanging out with you and she's trying to
use the axe
you can't mansplain to her you know
right because then women get angry and
get offended
i don't know if if i meet a man really
good at lumberjacking i just wouldn't
i'll just watch
right yeah i don't want to just sit on a
tree stump be like take your shirt off
i think modern day peacocking is like
performance like like music
and being confident maybe maybe the
issue is
no more challenges anymore yeah how does
a guy impress a woman when
we have like food everywhere all the
time
like think about what people do for fun
these days this is what always really
bothered me
people would be like hey you want to go
out and do something i'd be like sure
what is there to do you want to you know
go to the parks i'll go skating well we
can go eat food and drink
things or watch something every every i
would say nine out of ten times
growing up in chicago moving living in
new york living in l.a do you want to go
out basically meant do you want to put
things in your mouth
[Laughter]
for me it did okay okay keep it together
lady
yeah but well you know and i'm like dude
i'll go to the skate park you know me
and my friends in chicago
we would take this the train at like 11
p.m
downtown with all the businesses shut
down we would skate around the city when
everyone's gone
that was going out late night and then
we got older and i'm gonna start
drinking
but then when i'm like in my 20s all
anyone ever does
is like we're gonna go to the cafe and
get drinks and and chips or something
it's like
yeah that sounds boring man like you're
not doing anything just eating stuff
yeah flame we used to ride bikes yeah
you guys ever do that
oh yeah rollerblading heck yeah going
exploring
we used to when i was a little kid we
would just try and push our boundaries
and
and ride our bikes as far as we could
before the we we we knew the lights
would turn on
we have to go home and that was fun then
you get older and you've like
you know you've got satellites you've
discovered everything what's there to do
i suppose a lot of people like we still
haven't explored every part of the
planet and a lot of people think that we
have but we haven't so
there's always something to go out and
do i guess okay you want to go
explore the ocean with me yes yeah
definitely do it
yeah like we have satellite pictures of
a lot of stuff but we've been there
for all you know there's buried treasure
man hey yeah there
sunken treasure buried treasure
all right where are we at
i can't read the super chat's name he
says tp has your crew figured out my new
youtube tag no i bugged it to make
tp joke to tp as i receive tp jokes
we tps are in high demand for in 2020.
well i hope that was worth the five
dollars because you got me
tim have you ever thought of selling
pool supplies pool supplies it's a good
idea
i think we can add what could we put
like chlorine tablets
on the site yes let's do it yeah you go
to
pool pool shops like an inflatable
beanie yes
and and what it does is it floats and
you can put stuff in it yeah
so it's in your pool yeah yeah you could
put it over your head and go under water
and breathe
oh yeah there you go headphones that's
cool
all right liberty tcm says saw christian
royersford pa
my wife and i loved it she was great the
whole thing was great highly recommend
that was an awesome show definitely
chris loves hax says
when you were talking about gingers i
thought of the scene from game of
thrones
when tormund's uh tormund says gingers
are beautiful
they are kissed by fire wow i like that
the texan 83 says ginger's having no
souls has been debunked him
if they didn't then thanos would have
never gotten the gotten the soul stone
nor would hawkeye have been able to get
it why is he a ginger or white one
hawkeye wasn't no isn't ginger then what
is it interesting black widow was a
ginger
oh i get it that's the point because she
sacrificed her soul
for the soulstone okay ah what is gamora
supposed to be a ginger she has green
skin
i don't know depends on the lighting
the scott says i call changing a ginger
for a poc
scabbling the the ginger like the board
game scrabble oh scrabbling
huh because if you rearrange the letters
in oh no we're not reading that
nope jonathan galterini says there was
an active shooter in colorado earlier
and half of the questions at the press
conference were about the race of the
shooter and victims reporters are trying
to demand information information on the
races modern journalism
wow well that's what you get it's
because it was in boulder yeah they're
desperate for ratings man that's what
it's all about feel like it's like the
80s all over again do you guys remember
how bad the 80s were by any chance yeah
yeah i wasn't there
i was i was i was uh three when the when
the 80s was ending it was so lame i was
born in 79 so like i grew up and i
thought this is what life is
big hair lots of hair spray crappy music
no
not all of it was crap most of it was
crappy
1991 saved the world no no no dude 80s
were so
lame it was just so much makeup and like
weird
blame for fashion never going to give
you this the greatest
song of this one
and like now i feel like we're in
another one of those like the kids
crap and they're like totally
disenfranchised by it
wasn't take on me and the push mode yes
yeah yeah
some of it was good bro it makes the 90s
look like
it does dog no man the 80s was the
hardest oh what is it what does the 90s
have closing
time radiohead and
pearl but it had it had a resurgence of
culture and
like after this crap in the 80s what did
the two thousands give us
nothing can we all agree 2000
sucks yeah the odds yeah but all right
all right pearl jam
stone temple pilots oh yeah nirvana
uh the offspring oh yeah okay 90s the
90s had
weezer early stuff okay i guess
yeah radiohead was here yeah radio had
said matthew spann more depression
dipped more to peshmerga but what
happened was after the crap of the 80s
we had like a cultural resurgence so i
think that we might be headed for
something like that we may even
have a part in it what are the two what
are the twenty times can't handle any
more
yeah seriously what do we get from the
2010 basically the intro to this crap
yep what no like what's some of the good
music of the 2010's uh oh oh oh um
what's that one
uh the weekend this weekend's pretty
good what's the one where the guy's like
i broke up with you
and now i'm mailing at you somebody i
used to know
oh yeah yeah his wife yeah
yeah that was that was all right but is
there like a band or group you can name
in the 2010s foo fighters are holding it
together but no their hot stuff was in
the 90s
yeah that was early taking back sunday
no that was super emo yeah that was like
two thousands
yeah i like that i like some of their
stuff though them and brand new
and uh that's a good band neck deep
brand new is pretty good you know just
listen to their stuff
yeah i guess i guess the audience had
that oh you know what daft punk's been
around forever so they they kind of are
the saving grace for a lot of these
time periods blink 182.
yeah okay i'm not crazy all right all
right they were able to like make
popcorn shut it down
cool you guys you guys in the super chat
you got to give us some examples of
good music from the 2000s and the 20
times besides britney spears
we're all buying no besides britney yeah
i mean rachel's
aguilera radiohead has still been
producing music oh muse
oh of course dude music is amazing two
thousands had muse that's
they were in the late 90s in the 2000s
and they're still around today and muse
is one of the best bands ever period no
joke
well i really like kings of leon too yes
because they're okay
all right all right sounds like there's
some good music going on i just can't
think of anything
it's clogged by all the the auto-tune
and all that i think what's that
is kill something kill switching killers
killers i don't know i
love the killers don't listen to tim
tim's wrong about the killers
oh franz ferdinand was hot too yeah
they're pretty good two
three muse has got some really epic it's
like madness
is just like amazing but they're not but
they're not in the billions
oh we have these are good yeah they're
20 they're from my hometown the 2010s
gave us
psy gangnam style yeah that's right yes
that was great
there's a lot of fun classic the
macarena for a new generation
that's drago drago dente by
what's the name of that band i don't
know but that's from the 90s isn't it
basically annoying
songs you hear at a wedding is what we
got as a 2010s
possibly yes well i'll tell you guys a
secret
you can tell the demographic of a
restaurant by the music they're playing
when you sit there
if they're playing 80s music you know
they're going for a boomers
if they're playing 90s music they're
going for gen xers they're playing 2000s
they're going for
you guys millennials you know and if
they're playing
i don't know what do kids listen to
these days i don't know
if they're playing rag mop they're going
for your great grandfather
rag mop all right let's see tia says my
wife's a ginger with blue eyes the same
as chrissy
are you aware it is the rarest hair and
eye color combination
also each freckle is a trapped soul of
those she has smited
or is it smote that's true i love it i
think it's smoke
smoke i don't know thou hast's fine
castle says remember when british and
some irish was the pinnacle of tv comedy
father ted the in-betweeners the i.t
show also hearing
tom cruise was worth the to oh also
hearing tim
hughes was worth the 10 membership oh
tim cuss
oh oh yeah there's an e i'm like what's
this of course yeah as well as the
interesting guests
oh definitely oh yeah yeah we swear up a
storm over at timcast.com because we're
allowed to
yes i guess it's not for the for the
kids so
buck brink says we need to start making
fun of the woke non-stop
then it wouldn't be cool to be woke
anymore it's not cool to be woke they're
just
people are scared into being woke like
who who wants to be that
you look at like that woke cancel
cultured journalist that woman
who's tweeting that she's a violent
racist who wants to tweet that about
themselves
she doesn't have the right friends like
i think the welksters they just you're
just you don't have cool enough friends
yeah you got to keep your friends calm
when they get called out by welksters
yeah this is why i i think ryan long has
some of the best comedy
when he did that basketball game teams
do you see that one so
you see this one ian he's he's picking
oh wait yes i did there's left
and there's right and they're picking
basketball teams and the left guy is
like
before you're on my team have you ever
said an opinion that is wrong or like
you know it's just like really insane
but the best part is when the guy's like
fine i guess i'm on the right
then the dude whose right wing goes hey
look at this meme isn't that hilarious
like that's the gist of the right
they're like
we can mean we can we love it but like
the guy begrudgingly becomes right wing
because the left guy won't leave him
alone
and then the other guy's hiding because
he loses his job he gets a phone call
he's like i just got fired
yeah that's great stuff that's incisive
all right let's see leo says coinbase
ceo announced the company
will not take public stances on
political issues he went as far to offer
a severance package to those that did
not agree with the company being neutral
five percent 60 people left the company
whoa
is that real why are they leaked because
they are whoa oh gotta look that up
sounds like this probably because
non-white people probably would just
like i don't care leave me alone
yeah it then walks out of there oh
that's great
all right let's see we got going on we
have a request for 4k
and then youtube does this thing where
oh now everyone's naming these bands
like crazy
all right this is good this is good
though i love it there's gonna be a lot
of angry people named pearl jam
how could you forget these great bands
yeah man
a ton came in oh yeah billy corgan
what's this band yes smashing pumpkins
oh dude the 90s like one of the greatest
albums ever written
all right fighters yeah dave grohl made
nirvana they were terrible before he
joined
he was so his harmonies and his drums
roger that trucker says please invest in
4k waiting to join your website when you
do
4k is intense no joke all of our cameras
literally say 4k on them
but ingesting 4k into a computer we're
going to need to upgrade that stuff
and the issue is when we did do 4k
before
people actually complained
because of the amount of download data
they were downloading i suppose i
i don't know if this is true now for the
live streams
but i was just like we'll just i mean
people are mostly interested in the
audio not the video component of it so
we just went to 720. is it 1440 is that
4k or just 1080.
for a 4k is 2160. oh
3384 3840 over 2160 is that what it is
i don't know no i don't think so maybe
is it 160. i don't know but you can
always down scale it if you're watching
right
yeah and then one of the problems we had
was that the original web hosting we
were doing for 10cast.com didn't have
that ability
so the higher resolution files were too
big for people to watch
so then we had to switch things up and
ultimately 4k is
way more expensive to host way larger
files way longer to
upload and a lot of people ask us not to
do it so we didn't
although we could theoretically have
more than one you know
uh for the time being i don't think we
just nearly need to do it
woodworking medic says men are told to
suck it up and suffer in silence
people don't realize how bad the male
depression suicide rate is because we
aren't allowed to talk about it
the future of relationships scares me
with toxic femininity
jack murphy had it right yeah yeah
oh what's this dislabled says chrissy is
a thief
who stole christmas presents from an old
woman
is that oh is that is that not real no
it's not real
oh but would you i don't know
why why would you do this no if there's
something you wanted
oh hey look at that dixie devil says
michael malus had a show on compound
media for a couple of years as well
yeah everything is archived i've been
subbed since day one and it's kept me
sane through all the woke
michael you get way too much promotion
on this show
well that's the blame dixie devil for
the super chat
the lee says the guest cam is always
desync with the audio
of said guest for me this just happened
one other time
because yeah we just yeah with siraj
last week so we just need to
fix it we'll tinker with it we'll get it
fixed tonight
i think i know what the issue is okay
yeah
it's a really really simple fix perfect
dustin rourke says the manifest theology
came out of christianity from humanists
who infiltrated it
these individuals were bringing in the
occult anton levay in the church of
satan thought this
do what thou will occult interesting
all right let's see do we have uh where
are all these bands
where'd they go i want to see some bands
who did the blowfish
oh yeah i liked them okay me too i had
their own
inch nails nine inch nails for sure
there we go atlantis morrissey
80s had ernest saves christmas enough
said
dude
ian check out the 80s band joe mans man
and the midnight revival band they're
pretty awesome and underrated that's a
cool name i've never heard of them
before
ian the 80s were the best times the 90s
started the downturn in america
yes i don't think so really party night
top gundy says ian i will fight you the
80s had questions yes
well the 70s had queen too queen's
queen was around for a long time yup
tool yeah this was around in the 70s too
wasn't he
joseph hoffman says tim you once said
you play destiny 2
are you a warlock titan or hunter main
my guess is titan i don't play destiny
anymore
at the time my first character was
warlock and then i eventually switched
to a hunter
i played warlock because i didn't know
anything about the game and just picked
warlock and then once and i once i
realized
you know and and got into it it wasn't
until destiny 2 i switched to to hunter
actually
queens of the stone age arcade fire oh
yeah you know what i
i do like porn yeah corn they had on
porn's got some good music
uh oh i can't remember the name of that
avengers arctic monkeys were great is it
the 2000's
yes tool airborne toxic event what is
the
most incredible oh the gorillas man yep
yeah wow how do we miss them that's blur
the guy from blue right yeah definitely
and that was two thousands well blur was
like 90 95 or something or 93.
system of a down pretty good that was
when i started a fallout of music
metallica that was 90s they were 80s 80s
metallica
they they actually kind of created rock
and well gunzero's kind of created
guns and roses obviously i mean dragon
force in the 2000s oh yeah
yes definitely dragon force is amazing
yeah baby metal
never heard baby metal a lot of people
saying avenge sevenfold
oh yeah queens of the stone age
taking back sunday brand new hawthorne
heights senses fail story of the year
the used thrice tons of good 2000 stuff
emo was the best
yes it was thank you taking it back
sunday had some good stuff brand new
really like brand new hawthorne heights
i think only had like one or
two singles i don't know census fail
story of the year not super familiar the
used
you know what man the used had a lot of
really great stuff very early on
seriously
compare some of the earlier lyrics like
blue and yellow
to the bird and the worm and i'm like it
seems like they just kind of
i don't know lost it or just didn't care
what happens with music yeah because
buried myself alive the lyrics for for
burying myself alive by the used
are amazing and like the structure of
the song it's really in-depth there's a
lot of words telling you the story and
explaining something
and you look at their later stuff and
it's just like that's how it goes
yep cake park okay nice and weird
he was so wasted he was like i don't
know how many albums we've done
back back was like mid-90s that was a
good
odelai is a great album all right we'll
do uh one more super chat here
mason swanner says tim if you are an
island with 50 other people no food
supply
only water how long before you would
turn to cannibalism
never i would die because you do not
want to get the shakes
oh what is it called uh encephalopathy
mm-hmm or encephalitis
i think it's encephalopathy i'm not sure
yeah eating prions
yeah you get the shakes
i'm all right is that why chrissy tegan
is so erratic
i don't know i'll just eat fish on an
island like there's fish you know
all right ladies and gentlemen if you
haven't already smash that like button
and head over to timcast.com become a
member because we're going to have
probably a profanity profanity laced
special exclusive members only segment
coming up at just around 11 or so
because we're going to record it still
you can follow me on all platforms on
all social media platforms at tim cast
my other youtube channels are
youtube.comtimcastanyoutube.comcastnews
this show is live monday through friday
8 p.m
so we will be back tomorrow if you
haven't already leave us a good review
give us five stars smash the like button
and share with your friends because it
really really does help
chris you want to shout anything out oh
yeah just check out compound media my
show the wet spot is mondays
uh at 7 30 p.m eastern and check out the
chrissy mayer podcast on
itunes youtube spotify and soundcloud
you said you were going to be touring
coming up yes yes uh my tour oh
gosh um i'm going to be in florida um
boca palm beach uh side splitters in
tampa
nashville uh huntsville alabama
um so many cities it's on my website go
to chrissymayer.com uh
everything's updated there you guys can
also follow me in crossland.net get on
my socials there love having you thank
you guys so much chrissy it's awesome to
meet you man
thank you for having me and you can
follow me at sour patch lids on twitter
and
mines and real star patch lids on gab
and instagram
we will see you over at timcast.com in
the exclusive members only segment
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you